[Musique]
Willy schran bonsoir Jean laass salle
bonsoir nous vous recevons pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview
nous sommes en direct Willy est-ce que
vous pouvez vous présenter succintement
main j'ai 54 ans je viens du pcalis je
suis né dans le Nord j'ai trois enfants
trois garçons d'ailleurs mon métier s
fleuristes ma passion c'est la chasse
j'ai même consacré beaucoup de temps
puisque j'ai décidé de m'investir dans
le monde associatif cynégétique et je
suis président des chasseurs de France
voilà mais je suisussi bien sûr chef
d'entreprise et puis là accessoirement
avec mon ami Jean a décidé de de faire
une petite expérience humaine pour
défendre nos valeurs au niveau de
l'élection européennne Jean Lassal
fils de berger issu d'une famille un peu
mixte à la frontière espagnole du côté
de papa tous goiste de résistance du
côté de maman il y avait que des
frangines dans l'une avait épousé papa
par bonheur les deux autres deux
réfugiés espagnols passer des joles de
Franco à la
guestapo et devant la guestapo Bergé
jusqu'à 21 ans mère 21 ans et sur les
conseils de papa qui me dit je vois que
tu veux faire de la politique gagne ta
vie d'abord et paye tes campagnes
électorales parce que sinon tu iras pas
loin je suis devenu ingénieur conseil et
depuis l'âge de 21 ans je suis élu j'ai
fait 27 élections j'allais gagné 25 j'ai
perdu les deux présidentieles où j'étais
pas
invité donc messieurs on a décidé de
vous faire venir parce que vous êtes
censé être connecté avec la réalité
connecté avec le terrain connecté avec
les les problèmes des Français comment
vous sentez après avoir fait multiples
meetings en France Willy comment vous
sentez les Français ce soir on va parler
géopolitique on va parler finances on va
parler peut-être terrorisme on va parler
agriculture on va parler territoire on
va parler immigration on va parler tout
un tas de choses wiy franchement en
colère franchement en colère et
principalement sur ce sujet des
européennes alors du dégoût l'ignorance
peut-être mais on sent que il y a
quelque chose qui se passe il y a une
déconnexion en cours les gens en ont
marre voilà ils sont révolté il trouvent
que le les choses se passent pas bien
pour eux il y a pas de bonheur il y a
pas de il y a pas de sourire c'est
difficile on est un peu près emmerdé
dans nos vdes ruraux tous les jours bon
la ruralité c'est pas un point
géographique hein j'ai autant de gens de
la ville que de la campagne c'est les
valeurs qui posent problème le plus moi
c'est ce que je ressens ce que j'ai
ressenti oui il y a une déclinaison sous
le pouvoir d'achat oui il y a tout ça il
y a un monde politique qui assume
peut-être plus ce qu'il doit assumer je
pense aussi beaucoup de déception de ce
côté-là et puis une Europe qui devient
un petit petit peu pénible on on a
essayé de rester vraiment sur le thème
de l'Europe voilà on n pas voulu faire
trop de franco-français on a vu que le
débat actuel était plutôt d'une lutte
interne ça c'est un peu con fallait
quand même plutôt reconcentrer les
choses sur le sujet européen les gens
ont pas bien conscience non plus qu'une
partie de leurs problèmes vienent vient
viennent quand même de l'Europe c'est
quand même là où on va diriger c'est
quand même là où on va écrire l'histoire
au degré supérieur voilà il reste pas
grand-chose à faire effectivement en
franco-français si on veut vraiment se
se poser les questions donc une
poudrière mais qui n'explose pas
beaucoup dans le fond hein pour plein de
raisons peut-être mais je trouve plutôt
effectivement une poudrière beaucoup de
colère beaucoup de collères
je les les gens ont peur ils n'ont plus
confiance en rien ni en personne ils
n'attendent plus rien de rien ce ces
élections européennes ilci comprennent
strictement rien il y en a même qui se
demandent s'ils ont le droit d' voter et
de sentiments
étonnant le
premier bon c'est vous êtes un peu en
marge et et c'est très bien euh mais on
entend rien et le deuxème
c'est depuis le début de notre premier
jour une forme de
joie à nous recevoir du monde partout
même à une visite à 8h30 du matin dans
une ferme
euh dans chez un artisan
Chise industriel de haut niveau euh le
même bonheur donc c'est c'est étonnant
je n'ai jamais vu une campagne comme ça
jamais je n'ai vu autant de monde dans
mes
campagnes comment vous sentez l'Europe
avec les problèmes avec la Russie les
problèmes avec l'Ukraine comment vous
sentez l'agriculture face aux pénuries
d'un Tran ou l'augmentation des coûts
énergétiques qu'est-ce qui vous font
remonter ces gens de
terrain d'abord c'est très loin pour eux
ça c'est sûr ils sent bien qu'il y a un
problème je pense qu'il y a d'abord une
première déception et ce qui a motivé ça
fait partie des choses qu'on a eu envie
de faire c'est que on sent que l'Europe
n'est pas ce qu'elle aurait dû être dans
la tête des gens voilà le traité de Rome
tout le monde sait à peu près ce que
c'est tout au moins pour ceux qui sont
un petit peu plus âgé c'est l'Europe de
la paix c'est l'Europe de la liberté et
le principal problème ou le principal
crainte ou le ressenti le plus fort
c'est un peu ce manque de liberté hein
il trouve que le voilà le cadre se
réduit de plus en plus on leur parle de
normes on interdit beaucoup de choses on
a une élite bureaucratique
technocratique qui a pris le pouvoir sur
les politiques qui peuvent être là-bas
d'ailleurs comme dit souvent Jean on a
quand même beaucoup plus de chance de
croiser un ours blanc dans la campagne
qu'un député européen on sait même pas
ce que c'est et c'est vrai donc des gens
un peu loin des yeux loin du cœur on
comprend pas bien on apprend des fois
tout d'un coup il y a une loi qui est
arrivé a si a là les gens et puis un un
un des
sentiments le le le plus mais c'est
normal ça va aussi un petit peu avec ce
qu'on a fait sur le terrain c'est un
problème de transmission alors
oui tu parles de la guerre on va en
discuter on parle de l'Ukraine on parle
de plein de choses d'abord une Europe
inachevée c'est-à-dire que on a fait
l'Europe tout qu' fait monétairement on
n'est pas foutu d'être d'accord il y a
encore toute une série de pays qui ont
pas l'euro militairement on n'est pas
foutu d'être bon quand il y a une guerre
aux frontières de l'Europe quoi qu'on en
dise c'est encore les Américains qui
doivent venir la régler donc même dans
ce domaine on n'est pas bon socialement
médicalement parlant train de vie tout
ce que tu veux pouvoir d'achat on n'est
pas foutu d'ordonner les choses non plus
entre nous on a des différences notoires
on se dit au final là où ils sont bons
c'est quand il faut normer et ça c'est
le petit je dirais morceau de bonheur
qui reste pour des tas de gens c'est
l'identité culturelle c'est les passions
c'est les métiers c'est les choix de vie
les gens ont peur de ne plus pouvoir
choisir leur vie dans les années qui
viennent combien de gens me disent tu
vois là mon gamin il ira jamais à la
chasse c'est foutu mon petit fils là
c'est c'est foutu pour lui ou il ira pas
la pêche ma petite fille c'est c'est
foutu je pourrais plus aller avec mes
petits enfants à la corida est-ce qu'on
mangera encore une c une côte à l'os sur
un barbecue dans quelques années j'en
suis pas sûr et ma bagnole et mon V8
comment je vais faire j'ai mes temps
machin c'est ma passion ma moto et je
peux poser une question mais je t'en
prie pourquoi pourquoi avoir mis la
corrida au milieu de chasse pêche et
tradition alors c'est pas chassp et
traditions c'est identité culturelle
donc on prend tout on prend tout parce
queil y a un problème aujourd'hui
d'intolérance c'est ça qui mène l'Europe
actuellement c'est j'aime pas la chasse
je veux pas que tu chasses des mecs qui
partageaient pas ma passion qui
partagent pas mes idées dans la chou le
débat il est utile on voit on peut on
fait progresser des choses aujourd'hui
on est sur quelque chose de radical tu
as des gens qui disent bah écoute moi je
manque pas g je mange pas de viande et
ben Sky je veux pas que tu en manges
puis c'est comme ça et puis je vais tout
donner puis c'est mon nouvel étandard et
puis voilà on se demande si c'est pas le
manque de religion qui fait aujourd'hui
qu'on suit de nouveau Jésus avec des
idées à la con voilà écoutez les mecs on
va se battre on a un nouvel étend d'ARD
à lever on a un idéal on est dans le
dogme le plus total allez on va se
battre parce que nous on veut plus que
des animaux qui soient tués pour être
mangés on plus qu'il y a des mec qui à
la chasse le dimanche pu les mec qui a
la pêche qui a la courda donc ça fait
partie d'un ensemble moi j'ai voulu on
est un tandem he moi j'ai voulu
réveiller cette grande famille de ses
valeurs rurales en disant les mecs
soyons tolérants parce que comment on va
vivre ensemble il y aura deux solutions
soit on s'entredéchire on s'entretue un
jour à cause de tout ça soit il y a
tellement peu de choses qui reste à
faire on n pas fini de s'emmerder le
dimanche après-midi quoi qu'est-ce qui
va nous rester donc et ça c'est vraiment
ce qui ressort la transmission et tu
sais à la fin de ta vie quand tu fais le
bilan quand il restera quelques minutes
tu as deux choses à transmettre
d'ailleurs ton sang
ou alors tes valeurs et quand il manque
un des deux c'est terrible et quand à
ton sang tu as pas pu donner tes valeurs
on a tous ce sentiment d'héritage à
donner on rêve tous que le gamin fasse
un peu ce que fait le père ou la mère ou
la gamine fa que père la mère les gamins
adoptés reçoivent les valeurs hein
comment les gamins adoptés tu parles du
sang oui le sang parce que c'est parce
que c'est c'est mécanique je veux dire
c'est pas du tout un reproche pour ceux
qui ont pas d'enfant ce cas c'est pas ça
parce que c'est on est là pour ça on
reste c'est le côté animal ce qu'on est
on est là pour transmettre voilà comme
tous les animaux s' couple et on va dire
l'être humain aussi donc c'est ça mais
c'est les valeurs et d'ailleurs tu peux
ne pas avoir chez corida on en reparlera
parce que c'est il y a quand même un
sujet à l'intérieur du sujet si ça te
fait
plaisir sais pas si ça me fait plaisir
mais je pense que c'est un sujet qu'il
faut aborder ça marche Gan l'Europe
tu vois la géopolitique commencer à
secouer notre économie quand tu vois nos
agriculteurs impacter avec le prix des
intrans le prix de l'électricité le prix
qui augmente de tout toi tu es tu es tu
es le berger chez nous qu'est-ce qui te
font remonter les gens est-ce qu'il voit
dans l'Europe quelque chose qui les
protège ou quelque chose qui ne les
protège plus trop euh pour dire la
réalité il s'en
foutent vraiment réellement
euh là
ceux que nous
rencontrons font t fort pour
s'intéresser mais ils on déjà plus
tellement de contact avec le cheflieu du
département contte tenu de la
disparition des services publics ils
n'ont pas grand chose à y faire plus de
maternité plus rien
et l'Europe alors là
c'est c'est le milieu où se règle tout
ce qui est
occulte tout ce qui met dans une grande
difficulté par contre je sens notamment
chez les jeunes et c'est pas nouveau euh
un retour à pourvu que la France ne
disparaisse pas c'est étonnant et pourvu
que nous perdions pas nos valeurs
attends je te mets une parenthèse je
demande à la communauté si le son est
bon de notre côté j'ai mon ingénieur du
son qui dit qu'est-ce qui se passe un
micro qui d'accord on va on va changer
ton micro g je vais donner la parole à
Willy pendant que Willy a un micro qui
fonctionne correctement je vous en prie
les techniciens on va se concentrer avec
Willy je te redonne la parole tout de
suite après que ton micro sera
changé Willy que tu as ton son qui qui
fonctionne
correctement le micro de Jean sal on va
le changer tout de suite revenons à la
géopolitique
Willy estce est-ce que les agriculteurs
que tu as pu côtoyer les gens de cette
ruralité qui font manger la la la France
est-ce qu'ils t'ont
dit qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire pour
nous pour calmer les choses ou est-ce
que ça va s'arranger ou est-ce que ça va
pas s'arranger ou est-ce que si je vote
pour toi tu vas arranger les choses ou
tu vas pas arranger les choses alors on
a toujours été sincère dans dans nos
réponses j'aime pas tant de tourup je
déteste mentir aussi ce qui m'a fallu
d'ailleurs pas mal de petits problèmes
mais bon on gagne du temps temps la
question que j'ai eu le plus souvent à
gérer ça a été est-ce que vous croyez
que les choses vont s'arranger pour nous
les agriculteurs la réponse que je leur
fait à chaque fois je dis les gars faut
pas rêver c'est non donc je leur
explique je prends souvent un exemple
assez concret aujourd'hui on vit dans
des accords internationaux bon on nous
parle souveraineté alimentaire moi
souveraineté alimentaire ça me parle pas
manquz de rien mais je sais pas d' à
bien entre parenthèses je m'en fous moi
ce que je veux c'est l'autonomie
alimentaire je veux que le mec du coin
il produise encore quelque chose et que
quand j'ai vu d'un circuit court je vais
m'en occuper tu sais que Sky que
l'Europe a voté le Green Deal alors on
va pas tout balayer mais c'est important
quand même ce point et on parle de
décroissance agricole moin 15 points
comment on peut dans la situation
actuelle estimer qu'on peut baisser de
15 % la production agricole européenne
pour une raison toute simple parce qu'il
faut faire de la place pour ce qui
rentre de l'extérieur et là il y a une
différence notoire c'est qu'on oblige
nous nos agriculteurs à produire sous
des normes et des contraintes pas
possibles où on nous vend effectivement
un élitisme alimentaire qui est souvent
d'ailleurs irréaliste dans le contexte
économique actuel mais j'y reviendrai il
faudra que tu m'expliques ce que c'est
élitisme alimentaire voilà tout vouloir
produire d'une façon merveilleuse
vis-à-vis des animaux vis-à-vis des
produits vis-à-vis des intrans c'est
c'est de la rigolade tu as vu quand on
enlève les intrans qu'on met sur les
bave il y a plus de sucre on peut
toujours dire c'est pas grave qu'on va
acheter du sucre au Brésil c'est pas un
probl je pour t'opposer est-ce que tu as
vu la qualité des nav
ratiques ouais mais moi j'ai pas
l'impression que le monde agricole est
responsable d'autant de choses que ça on
a sûrement fait des conneries il y a 30
4 ans VO 50 ans et je dis pas le
contraire et aujourd'hui ouais mais
alors justement le problème il est là
Sky il faut prendre au milieu est-ce
qu'on bascule dans le tout parfait et on
va tous en mourir ou est-ce qu'on essaie
de faire le plus parfait possible en
accompagnant les gens et pour pas crever
de fin demain c'est ça l'autonomie
alimentaire et aujourd'hui on est dans
on est il y aura un retour de balancier
d'ailleurs on le voit bien arriver ça va
beaucoup trop loin d'un côté et ça
devient plus viable alors je disais par
exemple 2035 c'est la fin des voitures
thermiques acheter 9 an en on est dans
un délire le plus total moi j'ai vu des
gens les 3/4 pour pas dire 90 % ou 95 %
des gens dans les salles nen auront
jamais une en 2035 bagnole électrique
ils en auront pas les moyens il y a
quand même un Français sur deux qui sait
pas changer sa bagnole bon faut juste
revenir à la réalité donc on nous dit ok
voiture électrique parfait très bien
l'Europe des grandes idées c'est super
c'est parfait on est meilleur du monde
tout le monde se marre dans le reste du
monde mais enfin on continue comme ça ok
donc il faut faire des bagnoles
électriques donc pour faire des bagnoles
électriques tu es d'accord avec moi il
faut quand même des batteries
électriques les batteries électriques
faut du L
tu sais qu'on a quelques mines sur le
territoire national et et oùour mer on
refuse de les exploiter au nom de
l'écologie punitive donc on achète not
lithium ailleurs j'adore prendre cet
exemple parce qu'il est vraiment
significatif et il est simple on va voir
les Chiliens les mecs disent voilà vous
voulez quoi les Français du lithium bah
ouais on fait des bagau électriques tu
as vu qu'on monte deux usines tout ça
c'est super bah on en a à vendre mais
nous les gars on n pas ça qu'à vendre av
bant vous avez quoi aussi B nous on a du
bœuf on a du poulet on a des pommes on a
du vin ah ouais mais non mais c'est pas
bon parce que les normes c'est pas les
mêmes bah écoute moi je garde mon lit
chin mon grand puis on va tout de suite
se quitter là-dessus he
donc un moment qu'est-ce que fait
aujourd'hui l'Europe elle est en train
d'écraser d'écraser que ce soit
agriculture élevage et viticulture par
exemple on est allé tu parles de terrain
fallait juste se rendre compte on va en
Gironde tous les deux et on arrive à
saint-émillon et je vois des des des
parcelles de vignes en train de se faire
arracher je dis merde c'est quand même
bizar muxlion et là les mecs expliquent
le marché va tellement mal donc d'abord
tu fais mal effectivement au viticulteur
et tu fais tomber le marché ensuite tu
pointe et tuoffres quelques dizaines de
milliers d'euros l'hectar pour arracher
la Vig via paiement de l'Europe voilà et
là le premier plan en train de se
terminer 1200 hactares arraché 1200
hactares arraché hein mais les Irlandais
c'est pareil tu as vu qu'ils ont 25
millions de têtes de bétail à flinguer
dans les 2 ans qui viennent pourquoi
tout ça et ben parce qu'on a des
politiques environnementales mais pas
que complètement mais complètement qui
dérape complètement pardon et on est
obligé de réduire notre autonomie
alimentaire européenne et française
parce qu'il va falloir faire de la place
pour rentrer et il faut le dire Sky pour
rentrer de la merde pour rentrer de la
merde donc d'un côté tu dis au mec alors
en plus je suis désolé de le dire mais
ces produits vont rentrer je prends
l'exemple du poulet chilien pas de non
pas de machin et là tu as pas le droit
de poser de question sinon tu as pas de
lithum donc ça rentre puis après bah tu
as ton poulet local on est allé à louer
on a beaucoup parler moi j'ai du pas de
calé il y a le poulet de lic tu as un
poulet labelllisé alors là les norme je
te dis pas la prpracerie les produits lu
ce a donné enfin les mètres carrés tout
ça la totale ce qui pas une mauvaise
chose non plus attention hein sauf que
tu te retrouves un camp poulet qui va
sortir du Chili à 299 en tête de gondole
dans les supermarchés puis tu as le
poulet qu'on aime bien qui est sûrement
fermier de bonne qualité mais qui va
faire le triple et quand tu es la
ménagère et Quand tu es dans un une
crise du pouvoir d'achat comme
actuellement et que tu as cinq gamins à
la maison et qu'on est déjà le 20 du
mois que c'est un peu court c'est du
poulet c'est du poulet hein au final on
achète donc les agriculteurs en fin de
compte dans cette affaire se font avoir
deux fois d'abord on les écrase parce
qu'il faut diminuer la production
agricole européenne et française pour
pouvoir rentrer des produits de
l'extérieur et deuxièmement parce que
ces produits qui rentrent en fin de
compte tue le marché de production nous
à ce qu'on oblige avec les normes le
coût du travail et tout ce qui tourne
autour donc l'agriculture actuellement
elle a pas fini d'en voire on va tester
le micro de Jean Jean est-ce qu'on
t'entend correctement dis-moi un petit B
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 on est bon on est bon jean
quand tu vois
ça lithium contre poulet ou lithium avec
poulet tu est-ce que la la la politique
européenne peut changer ça est-ce que
c'est en ouvrant nos trois pauvres
petites mines de lithium en Bretagne ou
ailleurs que ça va changer les choses
est-ce que il y a moyen de changer les
choses non pas du tout je pense que ça
ne changera rien vraiment et d'ailleurs
ceux que nous
rencontrons le ressentent très bien ils
sentent qu'on est obligé d'apporter du
prête à penser euh du prête à réfléchir
mais il n cro pas un mot parce que tout
ça c'est devenu mondialiste et ça il le
comprennent bien c'estàd c'est plus du
commerce entre la France et l'Espagne la
France et l'Allemagne et cetera c'est
c'est abstrait et ils comprennent pas
cette brutale accélération où tu es
perçu comme un salot parce que dans
diesel chez toi parce que tu veux pas
voir autre chose
euh pour le reste moi ce qui me me
frappe c'est le besoin euh c'est pas la
première fois que je le vois mais c'est
très fort d'être écouté d'être entendu
comme s'il avait un énorme déficit de
euh comment je devrais dire
de de se confier
et là euh au bout d'un moment
euh dans toutes nos réunions et en
particulier le soir où nous sommes je
pense les seuls à donner la parole
pendant euh une bonne heure et demi à
Sal qui se libère au dép ça vient pas
tout seul et bien c'est surtout ça c'est
pouvoir parler de ceux qui les
inquiètent au plus haut niveau et c'est
pas forcément la voiture électrique ou
ou le lithium c'est comment je vais tout
simplement pouvoir continuer à vivre
quelle place pour ma famille euh comment
je vais me déplacer ça c'est vraiment
une horreur une horreur sans être
déclassé aux yeux même de mes voisins et
les enfants quel avenir pour les enfants
et vous leur apportez quel type de
solution quelle proposition politique
vous faites remonter face à ces
angoisses ces
interrogations vous leur dites voilà
nous on va monter à l'Europe on va Esser
de faire changer ça ça
ça est-ce queil vous croi est-ce que les
Français ont encore confiance dans la
parole politique
ouou g comm puisque j'ai dit ça parce
que je le ressens très fort
euh ils comprennent très bien qu' dis
qu'on leur dise notre démarche nous
l'avons voulu passionnément et parce
qu'on s'est trouvé et on s'est posé la
question est-ce qu'on fait ou pas est-ce
qu'une fois de plus on la passer est-ce
qu'on laisse à d'autres de soit de nous
représenter où on y va c'est financé
comment c'estàdire c'est assez simple on
a pris une feuille le premier soir où on
s'est vu on a liigné 1 rien que pour
avoir le bulletin de vote la fiche la
profession de fois en espérant quand
même pouvoir se faire rembourser parce
que quand au fond je s
dit il a été élu par 9 1 million de
chasseurs à 98 % moi j'ai fait 1250000
voix malgré tout malgré tout hein malgré
l' faop la sa fraise à 0,5 et 1 % il y a
2 ans et demi même si on a perdu 50 %
chacun lui il lui reste quand même
500000 et et et moi 600000 donc ça le
fait si tu additionnes les deux puis
pour le reste nous avons convenu euh
d'autant que mon parti résistant à
trouvé un comité Théodule en face de
lui début de décembre dont j'avais
jamais entendu parler qui a prétendu
qu'on aurait dû avoir deux experts
comptables là où on en avait qu'un et
c'est l'expert comptable précisément qui
nous avait dit n prenez pas deux c'est
pour la durée de 5 ans puisqu'on a fait
les législative il y a pas longtemps et
un soir l'état m'avait reversé 100000 €
de trop payés pour la présidentielle les
deux anités de deux anités 2022 2023 euh
de mon partis sont tombés 84000 de fois
j'ai dépassé les 220000 à ne pas
dépasser même cas pour les Radicaux
valoisiens que j'ai rencontré voà ils
m'ont dit n on n'est pas inquié du tout
on a vu Emmanuel Macron qui nous a dit
écoutez donnez-moi de noms je les mets
sur la liste nous c'était pas pareil on
a été interdit de campagne on a été
interdit de prononcer notre nom et de
mettre le moindre argent sauf que il
continue quandme à tomber 86000 € tous
les ans et que au fond on
participera
venu à la hauteur qu'il faut mais nous
avons pensé tous les deux
donnera sa réponse
que le
combat était bien plus
important que ces soucis que nous avons
euok donc le combat est très important
donc quelle menace t'identifie pour
jauger le combat que tu vas être amené à
mener donc quels sont les trois bouillam
la la Wily la même question quelles sont
les trois menaces identifiées par Jean
Lassal pour l'Europe et pour la France
c'est qu'il a une sortie de route
vraiment il y a un moment que je le
dis vous avez vu la genantillè ça me
Rappelz mon tour de France je l'avais
sen dit très bon très fort ça ne sa euh
ça s'est réduit au Bonet rouge mais je
l'AV vécu intensément j'avais dit à
François Hollande tu finiras pas l'année
sans un gros problème on a eu les gilets
jaunes depuis ça n'est fallu ça a été
moins de et et là je pense que la
prochaine avec surtout les agriculteurs
j'étais hier soir à à la frontière
francoesagnole à Bobi euh franchement ce
que j'ai rencontré des représentants
agricoles français ou espagnol n'était
pas du tout du tout à la plaisanterie on
a une catégorie d'hom et de femmes
ordinaires jeunes et moins jeunes qui
qui n'en était pas du tout là il y a
quelques années et qui maintenant se
disent pour perdu perdu pour perdu on a
plus rien à [__]
voilà les les grandes menaces qu'on peut
qu'on peut avoir je je je pense que
c'est d'abord l'identité culturelle
française ça se ressent très fort en fin
de compte pour remettre ça dans un
contexte économique difficile euh je
veux dire les les gens sont prêts à
courber les chines jusqu'à un certain
niveau c'està-dire que ça peut être dur
financièrement ça peut être compliqué
avec toutes ces normes mais les petits
moments de bonheur tu sais ces petites
bouffées là qui permettre de résister de
pas complètement craquer et de pas péter
un câble et ben ça ça s'appelle les
identités qui s'appelle les traditions
s'appelle les passion parce que c'est
une référence quand ça va mal et
l'Europe qui veut faire effectivement ce
territoire un territoire fédéral unique
et on y est en nivlant effectivement les
choses comment on peut prétendre faire
des lois qui soient supranationales et
applicable à tout le monde de la même
façon je serai jamais un Allemand je
serai jamais un espagnol je serai jamais
un Italien ou un danois ou ce qu'on veut
c'est pas envisageable on arrive déjà
pas à avoir des lois qu'on arrive à
faire fonctionner je prends la loi sur
l'eau par exemple en France qui est
inapplicable entre le Nord le Sud l'Est
et l'Ouest et là on aurait tous la même
loi donc c'est forcément à chaque fois
au détriment de quelqu'un nous ce qu'on
veut faire par par exemple làdedans
c'est retrouver une souveraineté
législative française c'est le la seule
solution la deuxième menace la la
deuxième menace aujourd'hui moi je donc
cette identité culturelle ensuite elle
est économique il est certain qu'on va
avoir un énorme problème entre les pays
si on veut appliquer les mêmes règles
nous allons perdre cette souverain cette
autonomie alimentaire mais on va la on
va l'appeler pour l'instant souveraineté
alimentaire c'est évident la France
c'est ça ne peut pas être qu'un lieu de
de de technologie point tout ce genre de
choses il faut quand même y fabriquer sa
nourriture et ça c'est et on voit bien
la tendance générale parce que si on
répartit dans le monde lieu de
production on le fait aussi maintenant
indirectement à travers l'Europe déjà on
estimera vous ferez des central
nucléaaires et les autres font à bouffer
sauf que quand ça va mal on mange pas
des central nucléaire les calories c'est
quand même ce qu'on a besoin tous les
jours et on voit qu'on est en train de
déprécier fortement notre production
alimentaire un pays qui saura toujours
se faire à manger aura existera toujours
demain donc on a effectivement cette
partie là et puis il est évident
la dernière
partie je dirais les risques militaires
à voir l'Europe disparaître et on y on
est assez proche cette liste elle a une
fonction c'est d'ouvrir une voix
différente entre tous les milliards et
tous les chiffres o où tout le monde
s'endort dans les salles quand on écoute
tout ça moi le premier entre des gens
qui veulent faire des listes pour sauver
des animaux ou faire des listes pour
quitter l'Europe qui est complètement
dingue alors que il y a des gens qui
souffrent tous les jours partout il y a
une liste il y a une liste qui dit qui
est peut-être minusc qui fait peut-être
marrer tout le monde tous les grands
tous les tous les grands de la politique
en attendant il y a une liste qui dit on
peut trouver une solution médiane à ça
on peut pas être que dans la colère ou
que quand que dans l'ignorance il doit
se passer quelque chose et pour ça je
pense qu'il faut du bon sens nous on a
monté cette liste sur le principe de
dire l'urgence du bon sens Skille alors
là aussi c'est peut-être une phrase
toute faite en attendant le bon sens
quand on discute avec les gens c'est le
mot qui revient le plus et tout le temps
et tout le temps et tout le temps Mons
schran monsieur la sal il y a plus de
bon sens il y a des choses qui nous
paraissent tellement évidentes on a fait
ce Tour de France on a vu des trucs
dingues mais dingu hein on a on a vu par
exemple on a été voir un gars qui avait
une carrière de sable hein c'était dans
le Calvados le Calvados je ne savais pas
qu'ils ont un problème d'éco évaporation
ça c'est un nouveau texte européen je
l'apprends à tout le monde peut-être à
l'cho mais je le savais pas en arrivant
là-bas le mec nous explique quand je
décaisse un hectare de surface pour
enlever du sable je fais un trou d'eau
d'un hectare donc on me demande de
boucher des compensations effectivement
de zones humid que je dois acheter
boucher pour compenser parce qu'il y a
des mecs qui ont imaginé que dans le
fond s'il y avait moins de surface d'eau
donc moins d'eau qui s'évaporait il y en
a moins qui retomberit d'accord
raisonnement c'est du lourd quand même
ça fait quand même le tour de la planète
les nuages on fait quelques kilomètres
c'est le département d'à côté les
microclimats aussi sont générés par la
déforestation et je te r ça oui mais
expliquez quand même un mec tu Calvados
que quand tu cré un hectare d'eauf en
boucher x hectare pour compenser ce que
tu crées en eau et que tu fais quelques
kilomètres et que tu te retrouves là
c'était une carrière d'extraction de
tourbe la be qui est vachement connue
qui est une voilà qui ferme parce que
l'Europe n'a pas renouvelé pour des
raisons écologiques l'extraction de la
tourbe dans la Manche hein et ces mêmes
gens évidment vont devoir demain fermer
mettre la clé sous la porte c'est ici à
la fin de l'année c'est fini il y a une
usine rutilante il y a 400 salariés
là-dedans tout le monde s'en va ailleurs
voilà c'est c'est la la boîte à l'
arrête rassure-toi la tourbea toujours
alors ce soit soit d'Angleterre ou
d'Écosse ou d'Irlande ou les Chinois ou
les pays de l'Est mais faut faut quand
même voir ça ou quand tu es à boucha
dernier exemple quand même qui est
extraordinaire on est à Bouchaud les
mecs on a failli peindre les moules de
bouchot parce que quand tu enlèv un
piquet de moule hein et que tu le mets
sur la barge et que ça se récolte à un
moment précis les moules de boucha ça
doit être mû comme on dit elles sont à
la bonne taille tu as des micro moules
qui étaient collé sur les moules tuas
toujs quelquun qui se promène jusque là
les mecs il faisaient tomber les moules
les grosses ont les gardés de coups de
ballet tu mettais le reste à l'au para
c'est logique plus le droit de faire ça
l'Europe pas le droit peut pas mettre
des moules qui peent peut-être pas
s'attacher qui r trouveront pas le bon
piquet enfin tu es en délire total tu
peut penser que celles qui s'attache pas
seront bouché bouffé par un crabe ou un
poisson mais non c'est pas bon donc les
gars ont commencé à mettre les microules
dans les champs pour faire de la calcite
avec les agriculteurs là aussi ils ont
eu un énorme problème et là ça tout tout
à failli s'arrêter parce qu'on ne met
pas effectivement un animal non
euthanasié sur un champ vivant donc les
mecs ils ont troué une solution et tu
sais ce qu'ils font maintenant avec les
moules à la demande de l'Europe qui a
proposé les choses hein il faut les les
tout les tout petites moules faut les
passer dans un bas d'azote liquide ils
ont dû monter une usine pour ça voà
quand même le délire qu'on s'est coltiné
tous les jours hein ou même tu as vu
encore le weekend dernier hein c'est le
débarquement c'est les fêtes du
débarquement tu as vu longue surmer
parce que les mecs ont trouv un PF sur
un rocher le grand feu d'artifice pour
célébrer le débarquement de la plage de
longue surmer annulé au nom de
l'écologie conservateur du littoral on
est désolé on a trouvé un oiseau protégé
pas de feu d'artifice moi quand même
jusquau et ben ça on l'a vu partout moi
je suis très inquiet pour notre économie
on se rend pas compte parce que c'est
des micros histoires qui sont pas
beaucoup reprises mais des histoires
comme ça il y en a peut-être 200 tous
les jours en France mais qu'est-ce qui
va rester de l'économie qu'est-ce qui
comment on va Leser nourrir les gens on
va pas tous aller bosser dans nucléaire
on va pas tous faire de la haute
technologie comment on va faire ou quand
tu vois nos agriculteurs qui t'exlique
le plus gros problème c'est bon les
norme tous ça d'accord mais c'est quoi
ah bah on était en Alsace tous les deux
mec il dit problème monsieur schran et
ben cette année on ramassera pas la
moitié de nos aspges g nos fraises parce
qu'il y a plus personne qui veut se
baisser pour les ramasser on trouve même
plus quelqu'un employé alors là tu as un
vrai problème par sur l'immigration hein
tu as trois immigrations en Europe qui
sont bien distinctes la première c'est
peut-être des gens qui devraient pas se
trouver là et là il y a toutes les lois
qui sont toujours pas mises en
application correctement faisons bosser
le Frontex comme il doit et quand un qtf
se promène encore 4 ans après dans ce
pays il y a quand même un petit problème
alors qu'on est un peu près fliqué
surtout du matin jusqu'au soir faut
quand même pas déconner qu'onarrive pas
à les trouver et qu'on les renvoie et ça
on ' veut pas on est tous d'accord tu as
une immigration qui traverse moi je suis
du P decalé je sais ce que c'est tu as
des mecs qui veulent juste traverser
notre pays enfin des mecs hommes des
familles d'ailleurs hein des des gens
des des malheureux comme on dit chez
nous et qui veulent aller en Angleterre
on les empêche de passer on a collé la
frontière sur la plage de Calais comment
on n'arrive pas à régler ce problème
donc tu as des gens là que tu tiens
comme des lions en cage et qui
deviennent fous il y en a des milliers
qui attendent tous les jours avec toutes
les horreur qui se passe des gens
écrasés sur les routes les mecs qui sont
en bateau avec des enfants enfin
laissons passer ces gens la troisème
immigration celle dans le fond qui qui
aujourd'hui est totalement amalgamée
avec le reste bah c'est des gens qui
écrivent à la France et qui disent moi
je vais venir travailler quelle
meilleure assimilation quelle meilleure
façon d'intégrer un pays que de venir en
Bosson et avec l' envie de travailler et
on en manque tous les jours si Erdogan
il décide d'ouvrir sa frontière comme
nous on pourrait ouvrir notre frontière
avec l'Angleterre qu'est-ce qui se
passerait mais qu'est-ce qui se
passerait alors je sais pas évidavi
d'Erdogan ce que ça donnerait mais du
côté de chez nous faut juste voir
l'enfer qu'on fait vivre à ces gens et
l'enfer qu'on fait vivre aux gens qui
habitent dans ces zonesl c'est très
compliqué tu empêches une immigration de
voilà humaine une migration humaine je
crois qu'on a jamais fait
ça en Europe on n jamais empêché des
gens d'aller d'un point un autre en les
bloquant dans un pays en disant vous
restez là mais ils veulent pas rester là
tu les mets dans des bus on les amène
dans des centres à droite à gauche ils
reviennent dès qu'ils sont sortis du bus
Jean qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les
migrants qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec G qui
passent pas la frontière ou qui sont
stationnés à la frontière ou qui sont
dans des camps de rétention
administratif qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
c'est ces personnes là gens mais pour
l'instant c'est très exactement ce que
dit Willy c'est c'est vraiment très
étonnant et très
frappant il y a un sentiment
d'incompréhension total de la part de
ceux qui le vivent mais je pense que le
sentiment est hélas partagé par ceux qui
sont censés euh faire en sorte de
trouver une solution parce que euh tu tu
as ils sont en groupe tu peux peut-être
imaginer qu'il pourrait passer et puis
tout d'un coup tu as une décision
administrative qui te les envoies à 150
200 km tous éparpillés il faut tout
recommencer à zéro donc là il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de d'incompréhension
et pour le reste je crois qu'on euh on
force beaucoup le le problème euh en
nettant que beaucoup de nos entreprises
euh sont obligés d'arrêter faute de main
d'œuvre et que
l'immigration je n'ai pas de chiffre
mais je le vois je le voyais à
l'Assemblée nationale quand j'y étais
lorsque le personnel partait le matin à
10h30 après s levé à 5h mais tu avais
euh tout le monde venait de l'autre côté
de la Méditerranée ou d'autres pays
est-ce qu' est-ce que est-ce que les
camps de réfugiés qui a soit aux
frontières de l'Europe soit en Europe
est-ce qu'il faut dispatcher ces gens au
sein de des campagnes françaises mais
non mais parce que à mon avis non parce
que on est pas du tout prêt pour ça
c'est pardon tu les c'est un énorme
travail culturel euh ça ce ce que vous
dites Sky c'est très juste lorsqu'il y a
une commune ou un groupe de communes qui
a décrété qui a décidé après avoir
réfléchi on accueil et on va accueillir
c'est pas beaucoup hein on va accueillir
5 si réfugiés et ça devient une source
de satisfaction et de promotion même
pour tout le monde pour les mares qui ne
sont pas des avoués alors que même il
peut y avoir le même sentiment
d'exclusion et de racisme mais là ça se
passe bien mais culturellement on est à
des années lumières d'être près là donc
si vous les envoyez bien aussitôt vous
allez avoir des
affrontements parce que euh l'URE aura
fait il n' pas le choix il va euh euh
Flammer il va passer la nuit dehors où
il peut et il va inquiéter celui qui a
peur d'être inquiet donc ce n'est
surtout pas la solution pour l'instant
mais euh je pense que pendant cette
grande crise qui à mon avis ne fait que
commencer ça pourrait être un début de
solution parce que dans nos campagne on
sait faire alors c'était pas on a
accueilli ma famille par exemple
accueilli je le disais je vous le disais
tout à l'heure des Espagnols euh je ne
dis pas le nombre d'Italiens qu'on avait
accueilli auparavant ils sont
aujourd'hui parfaitement intégrés
l'affaire de quandême de de ceux qui ont
dû quitter l'Algérie il y a beaucoup
plus longtemps bon ça s'est pas passé
surfu tranquille mais enfit ça finit par
se faire mais il y avait je devrais dire
une
euh une idée même chez ceux qui s'en
défendaient de c'est mon prochain
quelque part quelque chose comme ça
c'est je je peux pas quand même le le le
détruire le le tuer tandis
qu'aujourd'hui tout ça c'est c'est quand
même pas au second plan sauf si euh
quelqu'un le le le le le le souhaite je
vois mon frère qui reçoit des des des
des hommes des femmes venus de de
plusieurs pays ça suscite des par une
certaine curiosité puis les gens
découvrent qu'il travaillent qu'il qu'il
s'intègr et après il décid d'aller plus
loin parce qu'ils veulent pas rester non
plus c'est tout à fait ce que disait
will ils veulent aller ailleurs mais au
fond tout le monde les regrette donc
aujourd'hui c'est avant tout je crois un
sentiment culturel on n'était pas obligé
et puis nous sommes un pays qui est très
impacté par l'immigration parce que
notre histoire veut ça nous sommes de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée nous
avons eu une relation très étroite avec
un très grand nombre de ces pays mais
nous n'avions vu qu'un des côtés le côté
colonisateur nous n'avions pas vu que il
pouvait arriver et aujourd'hui on est
aussi là-dedans
Wily sur l'immigration sur est-ce qu'on
dispatche euh euh les les réfugiés dans
nos campagnes françaises déserté et
désertiques non on peut pas parler comme
ça c'est pas ça du tout hein quand on
doit accueillir quelqu'un en France
d'abord faut qu'il le demande il faut
qu'il le veuille bon il y en a qui le
font donc il faut pas faire d'amalgame
autour de ça aujourd'hui certains
veulent tout mélanger en terme
d'immigration et ça ça m'est
insupportable on a tout t une histoire
migratoire dans notre sent on sa tous
qui plus et moins dans une région du
nord de la France qui est une région qui
a vu différentes vagues successives je
prends par exemple les Polonais qui
voilà qui font ces gens sont venus pour
des valeurs de travail donc je pense
c'est quoi le fromage de ta région le
Marwal pour le Nord effectivement et
puis bon on a plein de plein de fromages
locaux on n pas très riche dans ce
domaine mais on a quand même des petits
fromages locaux mais le Marwal c'est
souvent ce qu'on met en avant pour le
Nord Pas De calis il Marwal ou les
dérivés de Marwal mais donc je disais
oui on a des gens qui veulent venir chez
nous on fait un amalgame comment on peut
dispatcher des gens dans des territoires
européens enfin quand même quand on
prend le terme entre nous bon toi tu vas
prendre c'estot c'est le mot qui est
utilisé par l'Europe je c ah mais je
peux pas je peux pas l'accepter alors
toi tu vas prendre un quotat de 3000 toi
tu prends un quota de 8000 toi un quotat
de 3000 c'est des êtres humains un
quotat de 8000 donc tu fais venir des
gens pris au hasard qui veulent même pas
être là donc il faut revoir complètement
la politique migratoire donc il faut des
frontière c'est vrai plus ou moins fermé
quand même on on peut pas rentrer tout
le monde mais surtout faire rentrer les
gens qui veulent venir chez nous et qui
ont des raisons de venir et puis après
on a mis dans ce programme aussi par
exemple c'est quoi une raison de venir
bah venir s'intégrer travailler parce
que chez eux c'est compliqué parce qu'il
on la guerre c'est parce que c'est parce
qu'il y a la guerre parce qu'il y a des
tas de choses mais aujourd'hui quand
même le jeu que joue l'Angleterre sur
laessus à calis mais c'est dégueulasse
ils sont en train d'utiliser une masse
une masse de travail humaine je vais
l'appeler comme ça qui rentre à bas prix
et qui passe la la mer avec des sur des
canaux pneumatiques tout le monde fait
la fine bouche là-bas mais en attendant
Nant toujours pas changer la loi le
droit du sol est toujours appliqué hein
on en reparlera de la situation brexit
et compagnie avec ce qu' sont en train
de rentrer comme mecs qui sont payés au
lance-pierre parce que c'est ça la
vérité il faut le dire hein et les
Anglais ils sont super conforts dans
cette affaire la frontière sur la plage
de Calais c'est pas de notre faute vous
rentrez c'est bien tu vas gagner ça et
puis tu marnes on verra l'économie
anglaise dans 10 ans dans quel état va
être elle va être au top parce que quand
tu rentres un flux migratoire comme ça
pour rien pour rien hein parce qu'ils
auraient pu changer leur statut ils
auraient pu modifier les choses donc tu
vois bien que c'est parce qu'ils veulent
ils veulent donc en plus ils nous
emmerdent tous les jours avec ça à faire
la fine bouche alors qu'ils ne font rien
dans le fond pour empêcher on donne
quelques dizaines de millions d'euros à
la France pour tenir une frontière mais
qui qui est ingérable et qui est
intenable voilà et puis au final les
gens ils arrivent quand même donc c'est
ch avec les Turcs non ah les Turcs
aujourd'hui les Turcs regardez la
communauté turque est-ce que c'est une
communauté qui pose problème on donne de
l'argent à Erdogan pour qu'il stock dans
des camp de réfugiés 2 stock pas des
Turcs il stock aussi
différents je dirais personnes qui
veulent venir tu as aussi du syrien tu
as aussi des gens comme ça bon donc on
stock là-bas moi je dis on peut pas
stocker enfin tu imagines les termes on
stock des gens maintenant regardons qui
veut venir en France qui veut aller en
Allemagne qui veut qu'est-ce qu'on a
besoin je on parle quand même de ce
problème de main d'œuvre on dirait que
ça n'intéresse pas aujourd'hui la France
d'entrer de la main d'œuvre alors qu'il
y a une vraie place d'intégration àendre
voir d'assimilation par la valeur du
travail et on en a besoin on s'est pu
ramasser le muget au 1ierer mai parce
que plus personne veut venir on s'est pu
ramasser les chau-fleurs dans le Maréis
de saint-omé on s'est pas ramasser les
asperg et les fraises en Alsace est-ce
qu'on sait augmenter les salaires en
France bah aujourd'hui au point où on
est on est là le salaire évidemment on
est trop bas moi je le vois bien mais
attention parce que c'est là c'est là
toute la difficulté qu'on a géré on est
déjà dans des salaires hauts par rapport
aux autres pays européens vous l'avez
tous bien compris c'est pas pour rien
que les grosses entreprises s vont des
fois à l'autre bout de l'Europe vont
dans les pays de l'Est européens certes
mais on a bien compris donc comment
faire ça c'est quand même pas normal si
on est européen oui je sais bien que
c'est une histoire de pognon ils ont pas
vu ce qu'a fait Sky mais oui évidemment
c'est une histoire de poignon il y a des
intérêts il y a il y a quand même enfin
on nous prend quand même vraiment pour
des cons sur C sur ce sujet là mais
alors quelle est la part de la France
qui va rester dans ça force c'est qu' tu
dis qu'on nous prend pour des cons mais
c'est à force c'est qu'on doit être un
peu quand même ah mais tant que ça
marche mais c'est merveilleux mais
pourquoi changer mais pourquoi changer
combien de fois je suis dans on est dans
les meetings je dis il y a des jeunes on
a beaucoup de jeunes qui vient je met
les gamins je dis moi je fais partie
peut-être de la dernière génération
d'hom de femmes libres qui sont nées
dans ce pays j vous rendez pas compte on
est en train d'écrire toutes vos vies à
la place on est en train de d'écrire ce
que vous allez manger dans quoi vous
allez rouler ce que vous allez porter
comme Fring quelles vont être vos
passions on va même vous créer une
nouvelle identité culturelle parce qu'on
est en train d'interdire tout ce qui
dérange on va vous formater quelle est
ton interprétation de de ce que tu
décris comme ça une des raisons pour
laquelle je me suis mis en colère et
j'ai dit on y va avec jeens on peut
toujours tout accepter hein je après
tout j'ai 54 ballet le plus gros et
derrière et ben moi j'ai envie de
transmettre à mes enfants des petits mes
petits enfants ce que j'ai appris de mes
parents de mes grands-parents oh ça fait
sourire c'est sûr on n'est pas dans les
grandes équations à coup de milliard
dans le monde entier maisah des valeurs
une vie un peu de bonheur voilà
retrouver un peu le sourire dire qu'il a
un avenir et c'est pour ça qu'on veut
aller là-bas alors oui on est peut-être
pas nombreux c'est vrai on sera pas
beaucoup d'élus j'espère qu'on sera
quelques élus mais ce sentiment faut le
savoir quand même Sky il y a quasiment
tous les pays d'Europe ont essayé de
faire une liste similaire à ce que nous
on a fait
sur ses valeurs comme quoi que c'est
quand même un sentiment qui revient et
le profil des gens qui veulent créer ça
c'est quoi des gens de la vraie vie des
gens de la vraie vie on a 6 ou 7 tobib
des infirmiers des auxilires de vie des
commerçants et bouchés des boulangers
des gens de la vraie vie des petits
patrons et ces gens-là que vous
représentez aussi un petit peu est-ce
qu'ils ont connaissance des fondamentaux
de soutenabilité de notre société
thermo-industrielle alors présenter
comme ça ça fait un peu barbare et peu
ou mais ce que tu me décris là avec tout
le respect qu'on peut avoir pour les
tbibes les médecins les les les
auxiliaires de vie les mais ça n'est que
l'écume des choses et ben je crois que
le fonctionnement le fonctionnement de
notre société certes on a besoin de tous
ces gens-là pour être en première ligne
pour la santé mais est-ce qu'il
s'intéresse à la guerre
économique à la production énergétique à
la production de pétrole au recyclage à
tout ce qui fait notre société
thermo-industrielle est-ce qu'ils
comprennent en fait les lames de fond
qui animent notre économie et qui anime
aussi les marchés et qui anime aussi la
cupidité tu parlais de la délocalisation
dans des pays un peu plus à l'aise parce
que
Ctait vous vous en comprenez quoi de ces
lames de fond qui animent nos nos
systèmes alors je je je pense que les
gens sont euh tout au moins pour ceux
qui décident de s'investir plus au fait
que d'autres on voit quand même qu'ils
ont conscience de tout ça bon il y a
encore des gens qui bouinent
heureusement je sais que tu les fait
lire beaucoup ici Sky mais tu as raison
ça commence par le papier faut revenir à
tout ça parce que si on se laisse juste
intoxiquer parce qu'on voit juste sur
des images on est mort avant de
commencer il y a quand même de plus en
plus de gens et cette liste est composée
pour beaucoup de gens comme ça qui se
posent quand même ces questions et qui
essayent d'y réfléchir puis tu sais
l'écume sur la mer c'est peut-être pas
grandchose mais quand la mer elle bouge
beaucoup on finit par plus voir l'eau
tellement qu'il y a d'écumes donc donc
c'est quand même comme ça que ça
commence Jean l'a toujours dit on est
peut-être que des premiers résistants on
est peut-être que des premiers à se
lever c'est toujours dur d'être les
premers mais je te le dis on a discuté
de cette liste avec des tas deres pays
européens qui ont ce sentiment qui est
le même et qui veulent et qui veulent
reprendre les choses en main mais pour
une raison toute simple d'abord parce
qu'on a une défaillance du monde
politique au niveau européen comme c'est
pas possible
je suis désolé regarde les présences il
y a quand même des mecs qui sont payés
des hommes ou des femmes d'ailleurs qui
sont payés 10000 balles par mois combi
tu gages toi moi à titre personnel mon
salaire c'est 2200 € par mois le plafond
de la Sécu voilà voilà et puis quand il
y a un petit peu de bénéfice j'ai le
droit en prendre ça c'est ce que moi je
gagne il y a rien de secret là-dedans
tout le me peut le vérifier par contre
un député européen c'est 10000 balles
par mois quand tu vois que les mecs ils
y vont même pas quoi enfin il y a des
gens qui ont voté pour eux qui gagnent
même pas 10 % de ce qu'ils prennent la
moindre des choses quon est payé pour un
job c'est quand même se lever le matin
pour aller bosser quoi c'est quand même
un minimum alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui oui il y a un truc non il y
a gens qui veulent pisser tu veux all
pisser g
ou de camé tu sais où c'est avec ton
micro je vis je voulais le faire le plus
discr on va rester on va rester à
discuter avec le café voilà pas de
conneries avec les câbles câ c'est bon
pas fais
pas revenons revenons au pouvoir
politique Wily oui oui alors je disais
loin des yeux loin du cœur mais c'est
vrai à l'Europe on se rend compte de les
gens n'y vont pas il faut quand même
reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui la plupart
des gens qu'on envoie là-bas on recycle
quand même à peu près tous ceux qui ont
pris une branlée au législative au
sénatorial au régional ou au
départemental alors moi je suis très
fier on m'a proposé des tas de postes on
m'a proposé à chaque élection et
celle-ci encore j'ai eu plein de
propositions de tous les partis pas tous
mais suffisamment pour être confort dans
cette élection et rien à vooir à dire et
m'assoir dans un fauteuil ferme ma
gueule et me faire élire c'est normal
lobby des chasseurs c'est quand même
balaise ouais peut-être c'est balaise
mais j'aurais pu surout trèsaurais pu et
ben j'ai choisi un chemin de traverse
j'ai choisi d'y aller pour moi-même avec
un mec comme Jean pour qui j'ai une
grande admiration et qui partage mes
idées on aurait pu le faire autrement on
aurait pu se poser lui aussi il a eu
plein de propositions il les a pas
prises parce qu'on arrive à un moment on
a dit non on va y aller différemment je
te pose la question différemment est-ce
que tu sens que ce mouvement
trans-européen de retour au terrois
repli identité au valeurs à l'identité
culturelle de tout ça est-ce que tu
penses que ça annonce une bronca une
révolte de la plebe paysane ancrée qui
commence à avoir un peu de ralbol de la
déconnex politique de Bruxelles c'est
certain c'est certain elle arentend dans
les autres pays européens la petite
phrase du chasseur qui est même chose
garder la poudre au sec ah mais c'est la
même chose partout
oui bien sûr je l'entends bien sûr
jeentends regarde les Hollandais ce
qu'ils ont fait tu l'as vu dans les
différentes élections comme sénatorial
les Hollandais il y a pas plus je
demande juste à ma caméraman de me
réinstaller gens tu peux me réinstaller
gens
merci je disais il y a pas plus urbain
que la Hollande quand même comme pays on
est tous d'accord comment une liste
montée par des gens qui sont des
agriculteurs qui sont des ruraux arrive
à faire 30 ou 35 % de résultats aux
élections sénatoriales c'està dire qu'on
a des urbains comme quoi que les valeur
du monde rural ce que j'arrête pas de
répéter c'est pas c'est pas une question
géographique c'est une question de
valeur donc aujourd'hui les gens ont
envie de revenir aux valeurs à des
choses beaucoup plus simples beaucoup
moins techno effectivement avec une
alimentation on le voit une économie
tout ça mais je dirais à taille humaine
est-ce que tu peux poser la question que
je viens de te poser à Jean bah
Posey Jean il va te poser une question
vas-y Jean William Willy m'explique
c'est vraiment Willy hein je dis tout de
suite c'est pas William je vais
t'appeler Bill dans pas
longtemps je posais la question à Willy
si le fait que il y a un courant
trans-européen pour faire des
parties pour le terroir les traditions
pour l'identité culturelle est-ce que tu
penses que ça ça annonce une bronca une
révolte européenne des petites gens
contre la déconnexion
du pouvoir politique européen je ne sais
pas si c'est une Bronka ou une
révolution en tout cas c'est révolte
voilà peut-être en tout cas c'est un
élément très fort et qui est en cours
hier soir nous avons reçu une délégation
espagnole basque espagnol qui venait de
guiposcoa et qui avec traducteur ils
avaient vraiment tout préparé et ils
sont venus nous dire que hélas ils
n'avaent pas réussi eux à faire la même
chose que ce qu'il vouaient faire et
qu'ils allaient suivre de très près ce
que nous faisions c'est la deuxième fois
qu'ils viennent à nos réunions ils ont
la salle donc c'est compliqué non non
ils ont pas vous j' non plus ils nont
pas vous parce que moi j'ai essayé faire
une liste européenne c'est difficile et
ils
disent vous
avez trouver le moyen de rimpliquer
euh pas en politique peut-être mais dans
les affaires dans dans l'intérêt dans le
bien
commun des hommes et des femmes qui ne
croyaient plus du tout y être et chez
nous ils aspirent ta revenir il a dit en
toute en toute lettrre et il
dit cette fois-ci on n'est pas arrivé si
vous tenez bon si ça ne s'effondre pas
avant parce qu'on en est là on narrive
pas à joindre les debout euh et bien
nous serons là la prochaine fois donc je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui va
prendre de l'ampleur parce que il y a
rien de pire que l'indignation est le
fait de ne plus être considéré
c'est-à-dire d'être complètement mis à
l'index et à l'écart qui que tu fasses
la situation européenne sans son
principal fournisseur d'énergie à bon
marché comment vous lisez les les
différents scénarios
que la l'Europe et la France vont ou
vont devoir
traverser les scénarios économiques
comment vous voyez l'avenir de l'Europe
et ensuite comment maintenir toute
cette spécificité culturelle à l'échelle
régionale alors que le gros bateau prend
l'eau alors au niveau énergie bon il
faut revoir complètement le le paradigme
qu'on a actuellement mais il y a qu'à
faucon c'est compliqué he ouais mais on
peut donner des idées on peut essayer de
développer de toute façon on est bien on
voit bien aujourd'hui qu'on est en train
de payer le prix euh le prix de
l'énergie des autres puisqu'on répartit
le coût sur la plupart des gens nous
entre guillemets on a la production mais
on la partage hein avec des Allemands
d'ailleurs qui ont arrêté le le
nucléaire mais qui sont obligés de
remettre des chamb des centrales au
charbon en route sans arrêt et qui nous
piquent une partie de notreitré mais
pour des accords européen nous on est
obligé de payer largement audessus de la
valeur quand même faut le savoir dire
les Allemands ou on sort de l'Europe on
vire pas les Allemands mais par contre
il y a un moment je crois que là on est
à un cap où on pourrait parler
d'autonomie énergétique par foyer comme
d'autonomie hydraulique par foyer par
pays par pays mais par foyer je redis
bien par foyer toute personne
aujourd'hui et à la ville comme à la
campagne on pourrait tous fabriquer
notre énergie sans avoir besoin de de de
dépendre d'un de quelqu'un qui nous en
distribué qui nous l'avons un pris d'or
je suis désolé quelques panneaux
solaires une microéolienne dans le
jardin avec un 4 m tu chauffes et tu
refroidis ta maison et tu t'éclaires
autant que tu veux sans aucun problème
d'ailleurs on est déjà bien avancé dans
ce système d'acu qui est complètement
freiné actuellement pour des raisons
économiques et pour bien masquer le truc
et dire vous ne pouvez pas garder ça
chez vous vous ne pouvez pas produire
par de test là ouais ouais ouais bien
évidemment voilà l'eau c'est pareil on
voit bien on a la même quantité d'eau
qui tombe en France tous les ans depuis
des dizaines d'années sauf qu'elle tombe
plus de la même façon elle tombe
beaucoup en masse en même temps et c'est
moins régulier quoi que le pas de calé
question régularité pendant l' hiers on
a été servi bon et ça fait quelques
hivers ce qui veut dire aujourd'hui tu
sais combien il tomb de tu sais combien
il tombe de de de M qui do par an en
France c'est un peu moins de 500
milliards c'est c'est le volume hein et
et il y a dans le fond euh moins de 5 de
de de moins de 5 % qui est utilisé pour
la consommation humaine et pour la
consommation tu parler des bassines non
je te parle pas de la bassine je dis que
si on a tous une cuve de 30 ou 40 m C
sous la maison on peut tout à fait
garder son eau comment elle tombe en
masse de toute façon c'est une eau qui
part à la mer et qui fait monter l'océan
en plus et qui pose problème pas VO
jusque- là on disait qu'elle réchaufféit
depuis cette semaine al il paraît
qu'elle refroidit al maintenant je on
gonfler avec le réchauffement de l'océan
depuis des mois j'entends hier à la
télévision que c'est le refroidissement
de l'océan qui pose les problèmes
actuellement ça fait quand même 2 ans
qu'on nous explique juste le contraire
non mais Willy je te rappelle que tu es
fleuriste ouais c'est excuse-moi j'ai
pas le niveau ça je suis un peu court
ouais non mais d'accord ouis tu as
raison bon bref mais je sais encore
mettre ma main dans l'eau de l'océan
rendte s'il est chaud au froid mais donc
on est bien d'accord
làdessus tu sais d'où vient le vent oui
oui faut le mouiller avant sinon tu sens
rien mais si tu le mouilles oui tu peux
retrouver effectivement la direction du
vent donc on pourrait tous vivre en
autonomie de cette façonl déjà et
enlever un poids énorme sur la
fabrication à la fois de l'énergie mais
aussi cette problématique de l'eau et ça
on n le refuse évidemment comment
veux-tu tu vois tous les maillons qu'il
y a entre je dirais celui qui reçoit
l'électricité et celui qui passe la
commande il y a tellement de trucs qui
fonctionnent et des tâes de mil000
feuilles de
d'administration de production de
gestion de prise de capitaux de tout ce
que tu veux qui fait que ton prix tu es
en train de me parler de corruption tu
es en train de me parler defeuille tu es
en train c'est pas de la corruption
c'est que le système il est comme ça
est-ce que vous trouvez que les
institutions européennes sont
gangrainées par la tion Jean par
pardon c'estàd je pense que c'est
beaucoup pire que ça c'est beaucoup pire
que comp oui va sou de per oui non je
crois que elles sont totalement déphasé
de la de la vraie vie la plus forte
raison du bon sens dont nous parlions ça
ne peut pas fonctionner parce que le
politique n'y a plus strictement aucun
pouvoir comme en France d'ailleurs vous
avez vu l'Assemblée nationale est d
pourquoi tu vas à l'élection européenne
si le politique a plus aucun pouvoir et
parce que nous allons le le reprendre le
reprendre non nous allons
reapprendre
à à connaître le prix et à le reprendre
nous allons aller dans un esprit de
résistance mais tu arriver là-bas
admettons vous êtes tous les deux élus
ouis c'est quoi votre premier coup
d'éclat si vous faites un cal tout nu
vous faites une une greffe de la fin
vous faites non mais toi tu as de
l'avance donc ça va oui non mais ils y
croir pas au bout au bout d'un mois je
dire ça
marqu j'ai j'ai eu fait ça chaque fois
qu'il m'a été impossible d'accepter ce
qui paraissait acceptable à beaucoup de
mes collègues et qui moi constittu un
marqueur de plus dans le fait que
l'homme changeit de dimension et
revenait au règne animal et qu'il
sortait de la civilisation et que nous
allions vers un monde impitoyable où je
te mange parce que je suis le plus fort
donc je vais poser un certain nombre
d'actes nous n'allons pas y aller dans
ce sens d'abord nous allons commencer
par écouter moi quand je suis devenu
maire à 21 an on m'a dit qu'est-ce que
tu veux aller faire à la mairie j'ai dit
mais je veux y aller parce que je veux
voir je veux changer le cours des choses
j'ai commencé par apprendre on va pas
mettre7 ans il y a que 5 ans et puis euh
euh nous allons reposer les questions
nous avons trois attachés parlementaires
chacun ça fait 6 ça fait
plus que ça
c 15 ce qui qume beaucoup nous avons un
des réseaux sociaux bon très loin de de
ce que vous représentez mais qui
fonctionne quand même pas si mal avec
des des pointes assez fortes nous
tienons au courant de ce que nous allons
faire et nous allons dans un esprit de
résistance reposer les questions alors
on n que les C qui semble nous attribué
personne d'ailleurs puisquon est à 1 et
demi voilà mais que quel regard quel
regard vous portez sur vos collègues des
autres
partis ni bien ni mal mais je pense que
ça nous correspond pas donc à partir de
là moi je critique pas les autresond bah
parce que je pour un peu tout ce qu'on
vient d'expliquer je pense que je pense
que le monde politique en fin de compte
peut-être pas tout le monde non plus
mais il y a une tendance aujourd'hui à
la perte de conviction sans déconner
ouais mais ça ouais mais c'est le plus
grave c'est ce qui explique l'Europe je
vais y revenir c'est ce qui explique le
milf administratif c'est le manque de
conviction du monde politique
aujourd'hui là il y a c'est peut-être
aussi le manque de responsabilité non ah
non il les avait ils les ont aujourd'hui
on me dit un minist ils sont plus jamais
coupables ah oui non mais c'est sûr mais
le le manque de conviction en fin de
compte maintenant la politique c'est tu
dois démerder pour être aimé de tout le
monde c'est une connerie monumentale ça
c'est avec ça qu'on finit en dictature
être aimé tout le monde ça n'existe pas
moi il y a des gens qui me détestent
profondément je ne ferai rien pour les
séduire dans cette élection j'ai mes
valeurs j'ai mes convictions lesquel
lesquel te dét par exemple il y a
sûrement des gens de essus de l'écologie
politique qui me qui me déteste parce
que je suis chasseur ou genre de chose
et alors j'en suis très fier et je
l'assumerai toujours je pas me planquer
quand tu vois le nombre de parant
l'exemple de la chasse quand tu vois le
nombre de politiques qui chasse et qui
l' honteuse cette chasse et qui la
planque on est arrivé là-dedans
maintenant pour ne pas décevoir
d'éventuelles personnes qui votent pour
toi je suis tellement loin de tout ça
donc savoir gagner avec tes convictions
mais surtout savoir perdre faut que les
mecs réapprennent à perdre hein alors ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui donc j on a des
gens on parlait tout à l'heure de
millefeuille mais le pire du
millefeuille c'est le millefeuille
administratif européen là tu as mis des
mecs le millefeuille administratif
européen par exemple sur la pêche et la
chasse comment ça se passe ça se passe
sur la chasse de façon générale déjà
prenons bien l'exemple on a à peu près
40000 personnes qui travaillent là-bas
bon normalement c'est ça bon déjà dans
deux à deux places différentes déjà pas
mal aussi bon on est plus ça près la
plupart des gens qui sont là-bas mais ça
explique le système en fin de compte le
système appelle la norme g si tu veux
rebondir tu rebondis quand tu veux parce
que le système appelle la norme parce
que la norme justifie l'emploi en fin de
compte c'est la complex complexifier nos
vie justifie le travail d'une bonne
partie de ces gens donc je la fais
courte tu as des mecs qui s'emmerdent
devant un ordinateur l'après-midi dit
là-bas ils doivent avoir une idée ils
doivent avoir une idée parce que sinon
ils servent à rien et ben il y a rien de
plus dangereux qu'un techno à Bruxelles
qui s'emmerde devant un ordinateur qui
doit trouver une idée c'est le mec le
plus dangereux de la terre ou la femme
la plus dangereuse de la terre et il
n'arrête pas d'en trouver parce qu'il
faut justifier sinon à quoi elle sert
des fois cette Europe administrative
pour ça quand on dit on veut dénormer
mais oui il faut dénormer allez dit on
coupe la poire en on av déjà la moitié
quel est l'être humain qui peut vivre
avec 400 avec plus de 400000 normes pour
réjentter ta vie tous les jours parle de
liberté depuis le début de cet entretien
Sky elle est où la liberté les gamins
ils vont faire comment dans trois
générations donc et c'est là que ça joue
déjà en premier donc il faut il faut
absolument casser ce millefeuille
administratif si tu reprends pas
d'oxygène Jean tu disais les gamins ils
vont faire comment dans trois
générations dans 30 ans B allez on va
dire déjà dans 20 ans finess aujourd'hui
comment tu vois l'Europe dans 15 ans
Willy et comment tu vois l'Europe dans
15 ans Jean en terme économique en terme
de réchauffement climatique en terme de
flux migratoire en terme d'accessibilité
aux
ressources je vais donner mon sentiment
vrai là-dessus je pense que dans 15 ans
il y aura plus d'Europe si elle change
pas alors plus d'Europe parce qu'il y
aura une dislocation géopolitique il y
aura une dislocation géopolitique de
l'Europe il y aura une dislocation
géopolitique de l'Europe faut pas croire
le brexit c'est pas juste une fable une
fable anglaise tu ferais voter les gens
aujourd'hui des déjà regarde avant Sky
2005 traité de Rome traité de Lisbonne
pardon c'est par que 55 g pour des 55 %
des gens disent non qu'est-ce qu'on fait
on prend les députés les sénateurs on
met tout ça à Versailles on vote le
contraire ce jour-là on a perdu
probablement entre 30 et 50 % des
électeurs en France combien de gens nous
l'ont redit dans les salles on vient
parce que c'est vous parce que vous êtes
pas comme les autres parce que vous êtes
différents parce qu'on s'était juré de
pu retourner voter c'est dingue quand
même parce que depuis 2005 avoir été
pris pour des cons comme on a été pris
pour des cons c'est terminé tu ferais
voter les pays européens aujourd'hui le
peuple la pleb qui voterait demain il y
a les trois/4s des pays sortent de
l'Europe tout de suite tout de suite ça
veut dire qu'il y a un problème quand
même moi je pense qu'il faut conserver
cette Europe mais si l'Europe n'entend
pas ces messages est est-ce est-ce qui
est-ce qui va monter ce qu'on décrit ici
nous à petite échelle en France mais
qu'on a ressorti dans la plupart des
pays européens s il y a pas une prise de
conscience de ça je pense que dans 15
ans et ben on nous sera revenu
effectivement à des nations
indépendantes les unes des autres parce
qu'on aura énormément de difficulté à
contenir encore les les gens dans le
système qu'on est en train de leur
imposer
Jean exactement la même analyse euh
d'ailleurs les signes à Vancouver sont
très très forts jusqu'à mant on a pu
dire même si on l'a pas fav gardé fa
garder que le couple franco-allemand ça
allit maintenant tout le monde se rend
compte que c'est une très très grosse
euh Bale
euh il ne se cache même plus euh tu
parles de des écolos Allemands
contorpiller le système nucléaire
français en ruinant sa réputation lu
mettant déjà le leur pour commencer et
puis
après le notutre et puis un un élément
qui n'échappe à aucun français mais qui
n'échappe à aucun allemand non plus hein
c'est que s'il y a une commande de 20
avion à faire c'est aux États-Unis qu'on
l'a fait et on essaie de dire que on est
vraiment ensemble pour le meilleur ou
pour le pire j'étais à la Commission de
de la défense pendant euh trois mandats
c'est la seule où
o non pas sement et bien on ne peut pas
faire des drones parce que ce qu'on a
ils sont pres inutilisables il faut
l'ingénieur américain en permanence pour
nous permettre de l'utiliser il fait
rien il est là pour valider le fait
qu'on l'utilise et quand au drones
européens qui pèser 80 kg beaucoup plus
lourd beaucoup moins maniable beaucoup
moins apte peut-être plus puissant pour
d'autres affaires euh l'Allemagne n'en
veut pas donc on est déjà sur ce blocage
très fort et puis euh pour le reste je
je pense il n'y a qu'à voir l'ambiance
avec les autres pays et ce que nous vons
de dire à à propos de de l'Espagne de
Portugal euh bon de l'Italie on pourrait
dire c'est des pays latins mais quand tu
vois la Suède sur un tout autre une
toute autre vision la Suède qui a
souvent pour nous incarné à titre divers
un modèle et où je m'étais rendu
d'ailleurs pendant mon tour d'Europe
j'urais été voir et le Danemark mais ils
sont très très éloignés de nous mais
mais leurs préoccupations ne sont
absolument pas les nôtres
donc la dislocation me paraît inévitable
c'est pas la peine que Monsieur ass
Solino monsieur je ne sais qui Madame Le
Pen aujourd'hui ou demain
disent non c'est
l'affaire c'est fini c'est fini et
justement au
contraire nous en reposant des questions
qu'on ne pose plus not notamment est-ce
que nous avons
adopté
le le bon module est-ce que c'est ça
qu'il fallait est-ce que c'est à cela
qu' avait rêvé ce continent qui sétait
versé jusqu'au dernier s entre frères
qui avait décidé de faire la paix est-ce
que c'est ce qu'il fallait faire à à
l'issu m de donne une baguette magique
ouais les pleins pouvoirs crédit
illimité et même Bruno le ma ministre
des Finances pour vous accompagner vous
savez c'est notre superhéros qui sauve
l'économie française avec le carnet de
chèque de la
France il faut changer quoi tout de
suite maintenant en Europe vous vous
avez plein pouvoir on fait quoi donc on
va déjà changer un certain nombre de
choses parce que la France est déclassée
où elle va l'être Bruno le ma va être
bien sûr monter un peu plus haut encore
mais les Allemands eux vont se rendre
compte tout de suite comme tous les
autres pays nous sommes déclassés donc
tout de suite euh vous allez voir euh
les turbulences financières qui vont
semblanté dans notre pays beaucoup plus
encore que dans le Royaume-Uni qui Ava
eu un temps soit peu anticiipé le le
brexit donc euh si j'avais une baguette
magique je
commenceraiis par justement euh ben euh
amener euh nos députés à bout de bras
avec enthousiasme avec l'enthousiasme de
ceux qui sentent qu'ils ont quelque
chose de plus grand
que qui les amène c'est le retour du
destin c'està-dire est-ce que oui ou non
on veut retrouver les les base d'une
paix durable quitte à revoir totalement
et on posera la question parce que on ne
fait pas peur tant qu'on pose pas des
questions essentielles là il faut poser
la question est-ce que de de noer n'avit
pas on avec l'Europe des nations on
verra bien alors ça va venir du jour au
lendemain mais nous allons trouver
auprès de Nous beaucoup d'autres députés
qui se posent la question mais qui n'ent
pas le dire parce qu'ils ont peur d'être
déclassé qu'est-ce qu'on encore peut
nous déclasser un peu plus que ce qu'on
a fait tout au long de cette campagne
rien du tout nous y allons avec une
détermination qui l' fait que grandir
tout au long de la campagne parce qu'en
plus nous y prenons du plaisir au départ
on se demandait d'abord comment ça
fction entre deux parce qu'on est quand
même de de on est quand même dur bon moi
j'ai trouvé quand même un granide du
Nord je pensais que les ménir n'était
qu'en Bretagne mais j'ai trouvé aussi un
homme et je pense que tout le monde sen
rencontre cet après-midi devant notre
communauté euh qui a une capacité de
réflexion très nettement supérieure et
il a quelque chose il a une complexité à
lui qui est d au fait qu' est très euh
prude il n' pas euh trop montrer ce
qu'il sait mais c'est fer un bisous
après Jean on oui mais je peux le dire
quand même parce que ça fait partie ça
fait partie aussi de l'ambiance parce
qu'il y a qu'àavir l'ambiance entre
Charles Le Le Pen oui mais on ne fait
jamais de grandes choses si on n pas du
respect et si on n pas de la
considération et je dois le dire unin
d'admiration pour celui qui t'accompagne
tu ne peux rien faire par contre euh
c'est partagé et là tu te dis et bien il
y a longtemps que je ne me suis pas
trouvé dans un tel parcours et Jean on
fait quoi avec la Russie on fait quoi
avec la Chine on fait quoi avec les
États-Unis on fait quoi avec les
ingérences étrangères une baguette
magique alors ouais une grosse baguette
un gourdin
magique pour l'instant strictement rien
je peux simplement regretter mais ça
c'est c'est mon point de vue personnel
que euh on n pas eu un homme dans la
tempe du général de Gaul pour les virer
et pour sortir de l' temp est-ce qu'on
avait pas mieux à faire lorsque le mur
de Berlin est tombé que dealler mettre
l'UTAN au milieu de l'ancien Pacte de
Varsovie qui était brinvallent et
d'aller faire de la provocation tout c
minut mais je ferme la parenthèse là je
pose simplement la question elle est
gravissime et elle est à l'origine de
beaucoup de points pour le reste euh la
mondialisation est devenue telle à tous
les niveaux dans tous les pays dans tous
les continent que nous sommes tous les
mêmes interchangeables sauf peut-être
les plus misérables les 3 milliards qui
n'ont rien mais sin nous sommes
interchangeables plus rien ne tient on
voit que les États-Unis ça part en
sucette tu vas voir ce que ça va donner
la non présentation ou la présentation
dans de mauvais conditions de Donald
Trump et le système aujourd'hui est
capable d'enrayer la Chine elle-même la
Chine ne tient qu'avec un parti
communiste qui est aussi dlabré qu'
était le Parti communiste d'avant
Gorbatchev et puis des mafias
impitoyables et le jour où vous on
dégommé la Chine qui n'est pour moi pas
du tout en danger ils la dégommeront le
système mondialisé et financiarisé à
l'extrême est devenu tellement puissant
que rien ne peut lui échapper sauf
peut-être quand nous n'avions plus aucun
espoir ce sentiment de résistance qui
vient de la nuit des temps et qui nous
anime nous en parlant de l'homme de
l'antiquité et du fait qu'il pêchait
déjà parce que c'était un homme de mer
c'est quel c'est quel bruit sourd qu'on
entend c'est notre pays qu'on enchaîne
là oui c'est le monde qu'on enchaîne
aussi c'est l'Union européenne qu'on
enchaîne et c'est le monde et c'est
l'homme l'homme on l'a dressé contre
lui-même et et on revient je reviens
toujours là-dessus euh nous sommes issus
du règne animal c'est les civilisations
qui nous ont élevé nous avons beaucoup
participé nous la France malgré nos
immenses turpitudes à faire en sorte que
la France s'élève et monte en
civilisation
ici le peuple est souverain la
Déclaration universelle du droit de
l'homme et des citoyens partout on a dit
de nous voilà un peuple à dimension
universaliste où est passé tout ça rien
il en reste rien donc on revient au lion
qui paraî-il n'aurait pas la puissance
de la plume ni la puissance du verbe et
qui ne serait pas s'en servir et bien on
y revient parce que je te mange parce
que je suis plus fort que toi on en est
là mais nous nous avons décidé parce que
nous en avons l'âge moi je suis
nettement plus âgé que que Willy mais
j'ai passé ma vie à servir et je ne peux
pas supporter d'abord le déclassement de
la France tel qu'il est programmé Willy
ce pays qu'on enchaîne la France tu sens
que la France est enchaînée là ah oui
quand on a al stom on est obligé de
faire des pieds des mains pour récupérer
une
souvé quand tu vois d'autres choses pour
toi les princip bagette magique ouis un
gourdin magique gourdin magique on fait
quoi avec les Russes on fait quoi avec
les Chinois on fait quoi avec les
américain législative française au sein
de l'Europe on retrouve notre droit
d'accepter ou de pas accepter n'importe
quelle loi qui nous arrive et on prend
des décisions là-dessus ça c'est
impératif si l'Europe veit rester Escalé
on la chance une baguette magique he pas
croire au Père Noël
ouais mais si on fait pas çay s'est
foutu alors c'est peut-être qu'une
baguette magique croire au Père Noël
mais bon des fois il y a des cadeaux
dans la cheminée donc on va y croire
quand même un peu parce que je je le dis
parce que je le pense vraiment je le dis
pas comme quelque chose d'impossible à
atteindre je je le dis parce que je vois
pas d'autres solution et tu dors
toujours à côté du sapin de Noël avant
de te coucher ah oui oui j'ai le culte
de l'être végétal mort comme dit le
maire de Bordeaux oui c'est vrai oui oui
je j'ai toujours aimé ça oui oui oui ah
tu le sais moi je peux pas m'en empêcher
je vois un truc faut que je le coupe et
je le mets dans la maison c'est
mathématique donc je le dis parce que
j'y crois vraiment parce que j'ai beau
regarder alors moi je suis pas des voilà
je suis un un gars de la vraie vie comme
tout le monde j'ai pas des compétences
extraordinaires mais je me dis je je
vois bien que c'est ce chemin là qu'il
faut prendre voilà et il y a des choses
à faire c'est norme cette technocratie
cette bureaucratie a un moment il faut
recentrer ça faut diminuer fa la
trançonner la table elle doit faire
trois tours sur elle même si on va avoir
une chance de s'en sortir il y aura pas
d'autre solution tu vas te pointer à
Bruxelles tu vas dire bon écoute il vont
plastiquer la bagnole le premier soir ce
que j'ai raconté avant je te dis même
pas et pourtant j'aim avec boutade on le
dit avec boutade mais en face de toi tu
vas avoir des des mégalodon du lobbying
en face de toi qui vont te regarder qui
vont dire bon alors écoute Willy le
petit na tu es bien gentil tu vas
retourner au bar qui est en face on va
te mettre une petite pinte tu vas
arrêter de nous emmerder on va te faire
un petit chèque tu vas faire des
coloques à gauche à droite puis ça sera
P je continue avec les cadeau de Noël
alors pour répondre à ta question Sky je
continue d'accord on arrive à 5 à 6 ou 7
allez soyons fous ça a marché super bien
on arrive là-bas puis il y en a d'autres
un peu qui ont fait la même chose il y a
quelques listes quand même qui auront
lieu puis on arrive à faire un petit
group là tu vois 35 juste bien bon on
est dans une majorité relative ça veut
tout dire une majorité relative faut pas
des fois être nombreux n'oublie jamais
que je viens d'une région qui s'appelait
le Nord Pas De caléis c'est quandême la
première région écolo qu'on a eu avec
quatre sièges ils étaient quatre élus et
ils ont pris la présidence ça veut dire
qu'il faut pas des fois être un grand
groupe Quand tu es dans une majorité
relative et que tu es élu au suffffrage
à la proportionnelle on va dire pour
peser donc il y a pas de petite démarche
et il y a pas de petit groupe et il y a
pas de petit il y a pas de petites gens
il y a des gens qui peuvent avoir un
destin là-bas et je crois heureusement
qu'il y a encore des mecs qui croient
parce que dans ce cas-là on fait quoi
non mais gens clairement il se claquera
la santé pour pour il a déjà fait une
greffe de la fin tu connais il ira au
bout ouis jqu'à son dernier sa pour les
problème des des gens il y en a plus
beaucoup moi j'arrête pas de dire en
Europe en Europe il y en a pas d'autres
des gens CER le moule et ben moi je
pense que le gens il va se clonner hein
dans les dans les mois et les années n
qui viennent je sens quelque chose il se
passe quelque chose alors il y a des
mecs qui diront mais c'est pas vrai
c'est tout ok je ressens quelque chose
ici et ça se ressent dans d'autres pays
et il y a des gens la salle qui sont en
train de se lever et je crois que pour
le plus grand bonheur de l'Europe et
pour sa survie sinon je reviens à ce que
j'ai dit 15 ans il y aura plus rien
qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec les Russes les
Chinois les Américains avec les Russes
dans quelle sens la guerre l'Ukraine bon
voilà à force de jouer au con on a fini
par gagner on a décroché la
on a quand même eu toute une série de
provocations de ce côté-là et à un
moment on n peut-être pas considéré les
Russes comme ils auraient dû être
considéré avec leur qualité leur défaut
alors c'est facile de dire ça avec
beaucoup de recul he vu effectivement de
la France j'entends bien sauf que
maintenant on a une équation qui est
quasiment insoluble donc il a un moment
va falloir poser quand même un bout de
frontière hein et puis s'arrêter là
sinon on va prendre des risques et cette
guerre va continuer il va falloir un
moment que l'Ukraine je pense finira par
accepter de perdre un morceau de son
territoire souverain je vois pas
d'autres solutions comment parce que
pour repousser les Russes il faut se
battre tout court je veux dire faudra
mettre des moyens donc à un moment on va
parce on est déjà dans la discussion du
compromis on a bien compris on nous
raconte pas grandchose là-dessus mais on
voit bien qu'on va figer effectivement
les choses à un moment ENF voilà que ça
s'arrête on aura pas le choix faudra
accepter une nouvelle découpe européenne
et on serait heureux que ça se termine
comme ça parce que sinon comment on va
en sortir les Ukrainiens un peu moins
quand même ah oui les Ukrainiens un
petit peu moins bon il y avait déjà
peut-être que ces deux provinces qui
étaient déjà des provinces séparatistes
qui voulaient déjà être rattaché
effectivement à la Russie alors ça fera
peut-être bon dire des teles gens
j'essaie de dire simplement ce que je
penser honnêtement cette partie-là il va
falloir à un moment prendre une décision
je ne pense pas que pour récupérer ces
provinces il fasse il faut qu'on fasse
une guerre mondiale pour ça parce que
l'enjeu est très important et parce que
les peuples n'ont pas envant qu'on est
déjà en train de démonétiser le le brave
joselski je sais comment il s'appelle je
suis frappé deavir à quelle vitesse
jelensski oui je c'tait un are mais je
vois à quelle vitesse euh les médias en
France même à l'étranger commence à
rappeler qu'il n'a pas été élu qui n'a
pas été réélu contrairement à Erdogan ou
même Poutine la Constitution ukrainienne
protège son statut actuelin oui mais on
commence à le dire on ne le disait pas
il y a quelques il avait il avait raison
dans tous les domaine donc on n'est pas
loin du lâchage euh et cette guerre sert
beaucoup les les intérêts des Français
un peu moins celle des Allemands mais
quand même beaucoup et puis elle sert
beaucoup à Macron Macron pendant toute
la présidentielle il a passé son temps à
Moscou euh Poutine avait beau le mettre
euh au fond de cette table en forme de
ballon de rugby qui faisait 30 m il le
mettait assis l'autre il restait bien
sans g il lui disait ta Russie va
s'effondrer tu vas t'effondrer toi aussi
et cetera euh quand on BR qui disait ça
comment c'était Bruno Le Maire qui
disait ça oui Non Non mais lui a été lui
dire et il revenait le compterrendu et
moi je disais modestement dans les
quelques rares émissions de télé
auxquelelles j'étais convié mais appeler
d'urgence le président qu'il arrête
d'All dire des insanités pareilles à
quelqu'un qui peut-être un peu déranger
de la cafeetière c'est pas ça qui va le
remettre plan et SAR et Hollande Macron
vient faire campagne en France quelle
perspective qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
est-ce qu'on va travailler oui ou non
une fois pour toutes un peu sérieusement
sur la
recherche de la nouvelle énergie
renouvelable est-ce qu'il faut est-ce
qu'il faut envoyer des soldats français
sur place mais pas du tout mais
d'ailleurs qui c'est qui envie d'y aller
et qui a envie de les y envoyer mais
enfin tout le monde a retenu quand même
un peu d'histoire tout le monde n quand
même pas totalement illetttré tout le
monde a vu ce qui est arrivé à Napoléon
tout le monde a vu ce qui est arrivé à
Hitler et qui était quand même quelques
temps au-dessus euh hélas et mais
personne n'en verra aucun soldat là-bas
mais tout ça c'est la perspective de
faire vendre des armes aux Américains et
et ça marche très très bien c'est de m'
mener ou s'il y a une trisème guerre
mondiale les chasseurs français ils sont
réquisitionnés par l'armée ils sont
obligés de se
déclarer est-ce que est-ce que parce
qu'on a un permis on est plus facilement
mobilisable comment ça se passe on pas
faire grand chose avec un calibre 12 ou
un calibre 20 dans dans une trème guerre
mondiale bon écoute si faut filer un
coup de main on est des braves gens on
va faire ce qu'il faut s'il faut aider
le territoire bien évidemment ouais mais
bon pourquoi pas peut-être effectivement
mais je pense que pour revenir à cette
Ukraine on finira par mettre la
poussière sur le tapis et puis reposer
le tapis exaement il aura pas c'est des
gens quand même il y a des y a des
civils russes des civils que disens il a
pas de tort laisse encore quelques mois
passer un petit peu de de de de je
dirais de d'ingérence médiatique en
France et en Europe et je pense que dans
un an ou deux zelensk sera détesté par
la plupart des gens le boulot sera fait
et un moment on dira écoutez c'est pas
notre guerre mais c'est comme ça que ça
va mais c'est comme ça que ça va se
finir après tout il y a même des gens
qui finiront par dire ils l'ont cherché
après tout oui non mais voilà bon allez
écoutez c'est pas notre guerre on veut
pas y aller on veut pas que ça continue
et puis on va oublier tout ça vous un
morceau vous le prenez on fait la
frontière là ça va se terminer comme ça
alors
parce que c'est très
c'est très
important que nous n'apparaissions pas
non plus comme des hommes sans cœur
parce que nous en avons he nous aussi et
nous savons très bien les atrocités qui
se déroule en temps de guerre et il est
vrai que les ukraéens il monflent sec
c'est vrai mais est-ce que nous n'étions
pas près des yoslaves le général de
avait même imaginé le concept des igné
avec Maass en Égypte le maréchal Tito
que j'ai eu le bonneur de rencontrer
grâce à une de ses petites filles
lorsque j'allais régulièrement à
yoslavie du temps de tit mais est-ce que
ça nous a arraché les entrailles que de
les voir ensuite sent tuer sur une
opération totalement téléguidée par
l'extérieur à laquelle malheureusement
nous avons même participer un peu pas du
tout et pourtant le sang qui a coulé les
types j'ai vu un type qui avait arché
cher le cœur de son copain que j'avais
connu avec lui à dubrovnique c'est une
plage magnifique et je lu dis mais
Vladimir comment vas-tu il me sort un
bocal le super parfait tu sais le grand
bocal et il était lourd
avec il avait mis il avait mis le cœur
dedans c'était une un Salau Vladimir je
l'ai mis son cœur dedans si tu avais vu
ce qu'il était capable je lui a arraché
la protéine moi-même pour l'enlever
est-ce que ça nous a perturbé un temps
soit peu pas du tout on a découpé tout
ça au millimètres on a fait des phases
des couloirs des ceci des cela et nous
étions les grands amis de yoslav qui je
le rappelle se sont libérés de avant
tous les autres de la tutelle nazie
voilà et donc aucun éat dam
malheureusement les choses aujourd'hui
passent tout passe parce que nous sommes
malheureusement totalement absent de des
sensations humaines nous avons sombré
dans une sans ciblerie qui a fait place
à la
sensibilité qui est si bonne et qui est
si importante pour que les hommes vivent
en société nous avons des outils féroces
qui sont implantés un peu partout dans
le monde notamment dans les milieux dit
de la protection de la nature et du
climat bon moi il y a 15 ans j'étais
complètement perturbé par le trou dans
la couche d' zone j'ai loué j'ai loué
une fusée
tout seul je suis parti avec mes agile
j'ai réparé le trou dans la couche d'
zone terminé il y en a plus donc faisons
de la réale politique nous aussi ça
durera ce que ça durera mais en
entendant c'est ce qui marche Macron a
besoin de faire oublier qu'il y a des
européenes en France parce qu'il y a des
des oiseaux comme nous qui se promènent
dans la nature et il a besoin absolument
d'avoir son rassemblement national qui
est aussi
fangible dans la vie politique à
condition de trouver le type un peu
habile que le fut le Parti communiste du
temps deterran parce que le Parti
communiste faisait aussi peur parce que
parti communiste avec le globalement
positif de George marché euh c'était
c'était pas
rien Staline qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
les Chinois gens attends la finir parce
que Sin je peux pas je peux pas tout
dire donc ça a tenu 3 ans le Parti
communiste mais bien gérer ceux qui
pensent et certains ils sont venus très
lentement maintenant ils le disent
ouvertement qu'en votant en
rassemblement national ils vont faire
mais c'est comme ceux qui votai Parti
communiste c'est exactement pareil le
jour on décide voilà qu'est-ce qu'on
fait par rapport au chinois les Chinois
on le laisse d'abord faire on regarde
attentivement on regarde ce qui va se
passer avec les Américains les Chinois
n' nonont plus pour très longtemps parce
qu'ils vont perturber C séeusement le
nouvel ordre mondial qui sétablit et que
le jour où il nous aurons ils auront ass
emmerd et bien on va les [__] en l'air
comme on la foutu en l'air l'URSS et tu
crois au Père Noël Jean pas du tout j'y
ai cru intensément j'ai été heureux par
contre j'y crois pour le 9 juin parce
que c'est pas un père Noël habillé en
rouge c'est un père Noël habillé à
Marianne qui va de nouveau qui va de
nouveau euh
revenir parce que le temps est venu de
effectivement
euh voilà refaire
apparaître un petit éclair d'espoir
comme celui que nous voyons tous les
soirs dans nos sales archiplain pourquoi
vientent-il qu'est-ce qui pousse on dit
c'est des Rion de matcho nos adversaires
mais il faut voir le nombre de femmes le
nombre d'enfants qu'est-ce que tu veux
dire là que j'ai la bouche tuas tu as un
10 bout de moquette sur la lèvre voilà
ah ah Paron ou oui
bon bon ça y est je l'ai enlever bon
alors euh ils sentent que quelque chose
est possible et ils sentent que rien ne
résiste sent ils sentent que quelque
chose est possible ou ils sentent que ça
sent le sapin à les deux ils sentent s
le sapin mais ça il longtemps qu'ils le
sentent on n'a pas entendu aujourd'hui
ça commence à sentir fort le sapin cramé
là oui ça s fort alors ils ne savent pas
du tout comment ça se passera ils n'ont
doncc une envie d'y participer ils nont
pas envie de se battre ça c'est évident
ils veulent essayer de continuer le plus
possible à subir plutôt que de voir le
SAL grouler et ils ont raison si si
Emmanuel Macron déclare la guerre contre
la Russie ce sera quoi votre position
mais il y a aucune chance qu' a déclare
aucune mais c'est un trouillard Macron
de de de première catégorie Macron il
gère les petites affaires que rothchill
lui a demandé de gérer en France avec
ses immenses
c'est quoi ta source comment c'est quoi
ta source quand il travaille dans le
milieu bancaire c'est ça oui d'accord
comme il avait travaillé pom Pidou la
guerre comme il a travaillé
Emmanuelli qui allait pissé chaque fois
et donc si si il y a la trème guerre
mondial avec les Russes et les Chinois
votre position ce sera quoi mais il y a
pas de guerre mondiale pour l'instant ni
avec les Russes ni les Chinois dit ce
sera quoi ta position on va essayer de
s'en sortir qu'est- tu ve que je réponde
tu dis tout est en train de péter tu
fais quoi c'est quoi ta position tu
crois qu'on aura encore des grands
débats politiques et des grandes idées
pour l'Europe essayer de souver sa pe al
dire au chasseur tu vas dire au
chasseurs moi Président je vais pas à la
guerre ou tu vas dire moi président des
chasseurs on va à la guerre les gars
alors dis pas donc ce cas là qu'on est
déjà à la trisè GU mondiale parce que si
elle est là on est dedans donc après une
fois qu'on est dedans on est dedans donc
on est obligé de s'en sortir on va
retrouver des des envies d'aller se
battre on aura pas le choix de façon
c'est çaù on automatisme les vieux
automatismes qui vont revenir c'est sûr
bon moi je pense je pense pas qu'on est
au stade d'avoir une guerre une trè
guerre mondiale actuellement du tout je
ne ressens pas les choses comme ça je
pense qu'on va trouver une solution
parce qu'il y a tellement peu d'envie de
la faire que je pense P si on trouve pas
de solution et qu'on cartonouver ça va
se trouver si on va au Carton c'est
vousu qu'est-ce tu veux on verra ce tu
rester après le carton je cro pe à la
génétique encore j'ai vu ce qu'on fait
mon arrière grand-père mon grand-père
mon père je pense que sans savoir ce que
je ferais je crois que je déjà où est-ce
que j'irai où est-ce que je nirai pas je
ne resterai pas sensible mais il y a
aucune chance ça c'est une question pour
faire pour occuper tu as fait ton
service militaire non parce que j'ai
étaislu maire de ma commune au moment où
je devais partir et que le conseil
municipal a dit si tu pars on émissionne
tous j'étais sur cire et c'est
valérieardesttin qui a pris la décisions
parce que il était pas prévu que je
devienne le plus jeune maire de France à
cette époquel euh voilà bon mais ceci
étant je ne l'aurais pas supprimé au
contraire cheveux bon celui-là était un
peu dépassé par contre ce qui est très
important et c'était une de M mesures
c'était de rétablir pour l'ensemble du
contingent des 700000 jeunes de l'année
un service civique civil
ou militaire euh du
euh 20 septembre au 20 juin parce que je
ne vois pas comment on peut refaire
société avec une population aussi
atomisée que la nôtre quel point commun
entre les hommes et les femmes tu le
sais que j'ai pu visiter à VO envelet
entre 1h et 5h du matin et un
agriculteur de chez moi à lour cher qui
n'a pas vu un maghrébain à par ce de mon
frère depuis depuis 60 ans
i l'armée européenne tu y crois tu crois
pas c'est obligatoire alors dans quelle
proportion dans la proportion et l'OT
temp qu'est-ce qu'on fait l'OT temp
c'est pas tout à fait nous c'est pas
l'Europe donc à un moment on est
européen on l'est pas ça me paraît quand
même basique donc qui est un traité
d'alliance avec les Américains je peux
le comprendre on va dire mais enfin il
est quand même urgent qu'on ait une
force de frappe pour se défendre en cas
de problème à nos frontières ou
simplement pour régler un conflit sur un
territoire voisin qui est un territoire
tampon avec une frontière de l'Europe il
aurait fallu dès le début et dès les
premiers problèmes que nous fassions
voir que nous avions effectivement une
possibilité qui aurait permis peut-être
d'empêcher l'entrée l'entrée en conflit
de la Russie avec l'Ukraine mais n'ayant
n'étant pas capable de mettre en avant
effectivement une cohérence militaire je
même pas parler d'armée parce que
l'armée c'est sensible c'est chacun la
sienne mais au moins une cohérence
militaire pour faire voir que l'Europe
est capable aussi si vraiment nous étion
nous étions obligés de le faire d'entrer
dans un conflit ou de défendre ses
intérêts on na pas été capable de le
mettre en avant on a C Europe DEP depuis
3 ans
il y a que toi à qui je peux poser cette
question là depuis 3 ans le le prix des
munitions il il en est comment alors
c'est surtout maintenant que c'est dur
parce que il y en a de moins en moins à
trouver les Américains ont fermé le
robinet ils gardent tout pour eux il y a
beaucoup qui sont réquisitionnés donc ça
pourrait te donner raison hein dans ton
idée de 3ème guerre mondiale tout au
moins on est en train de refaire les
stocks partout ça c'est sûr donc c'est
mais tu as raison mais nous on le sait
ça FL de tous les côtés et on a du mal
non mais explique explique parce que on
a pas tous des copains chasseurs
militadi on a un mal de chiens depuis
l'année dernière depuis 2 ans mais c'est
fort l'année dernière à trouvé des
munitions de chasse surtout des balles
de carabine pour le grand givier la p
alors la poudre alors faut savoir que
les alors c'est compliqué mais sans
rentrer en le détail bref dans la
composition d'une balle il y a des
choses qui sont totalement américaines
et là c'est un vrai problème parce qu'il
n'en voit plus rien l'armée
réquisitionne toute la production la
production de de de balles ou de
cartouche à destination de la chasse
pour l'instant donc depuis combien de
temps depuis déjà 18 mois et ils vous
ont appelé avant de faire ça ou pas pas
du tout rien du tout personne qui n
appelé ou monsieur schran prés chasseur
on tient vous dire que vous NZ plus
avoir de cartouch de balle d'ici 2 ans
donc on a une une baisse de de dans
l'approvisionnement dans dans tes
licenciers ça commence à parler un peu
ça non ça parle un petit peu on a un
petit peu de mal alors on est après il y
a une production européenne aussi il
faut pas l'oublier hein donc
heureusement il y en a pas beaucoup il y
en a une il y a un grand en cartoucheur
heureusement il en restait un il a
failli disparaître comme le reste
d'ailleurs on aurait pu et ça c'est une
des grandes questions européennes il est
quand même temps de relocaliser tout ce
qu'on a besoin au moins sur le
territoire européen à titre personnel je
le verrai bien d'abord en France tu
parles des médicaments ou des cartouches
d'abord des médicaments on a quand même
réussi avec la pandémie à pu trouver ad
dolipran quand on avait mal à la tête
c'était quand même dingue bon c'est
pareil pour la pour pour pour la
production militaire c'est pareil pour
les composants électrique électronique
tout ce qu'on veut il faut qu'on
relocalise on peut pas être sans ces
productions là essentielles sur le
territoire national et là je suis désolé
je le dis carrément français hein alors
oui à l'échelle d'Europe peut-être on
peut s'arranger un petit peu mais encore
moi je serais sécurisé et et je me
sentirait beaucoup mieux quand tout ça
ça fait sera fait à nouveau chez nous
parce qu'on a tout fait chez nous on
savait tout faire on a laissé partir des
tas de choses de cette façon-là et ça on
voit comment on s'expose aujourd'hui
donc oui il faut qu'on fasse des
cartouches françaises il y en a
d'ailleurs et des balles française pour
qu'on puisse aller à la chasse l'année
prochaine sinon il y aura un problème
avec les sangliers et les dégâts
agricoles ah ça oui pe on parlera des
dégâts agricoles après et des battuses
de sangliers annulé parce que la chasse
à l'aglue était
contestée c'est c'est c'est pas sympa de
faire un moyen de pression comme ça on
reparlera différment tu es tu es en
contact avec tes homologues d'autres
pays européens avec tous les pays
européens tu es en contact avec eux ah
plus qu'en contact puisqu'on a une
fédération européenne des chasseurs ça
représente combien personn 7
millions et ils ont eu les mêmes
restrictions de poudre de bal tout ça
partout en Europe oui on a les mêmes
problématiques on n'est pas
enc disons qu'on a perdu certaines
marques on va le dire comme ça ou
certains types de certaines voilà de
Bastos VO faire de Bastos on n'est pas
du tout pour l'instant dans la pénurie
mais il y a des trucs qui ont qui ont
disparu des gondoles mais c'était
suffisamment important pour que ça parle
entre les présidents de différents pays
européens disons qu'on on en parle quand
même bien c'est normal ça fait parti des
choses qui peent c'est arrivé sur la
table comment bah par un conabê au fait
tu as vu j'ai plus de balle parce qu'on
se retrouve 4 C fois par an à discuter
souvent à Bruxelles d'ailleurs où la
Fédération Européenne a des bureau où on
est amené à aller régulièrement regarder
un petit peu ce qui se passe au
Parlement et discuter entre nous à un
moment ce sont des sujets qui sont venus
sur la table bon ben au fait mais en
parlant voilà entre comment on dit entre
la poire et le café quoi au fait j'ai pu
trouver de balle moi non plus et puis
parce que les gens au début pensaient
même pas que moi je pensais que c'était
plus une problématique française de sans
se rendre compte que on était vraiment
sur un échiquet mondial là-dessus et
c'est en regardant et en se renseignant
qu'on s'est rendu compte que certains
pays étaient en train de refaire les
stocks complet de munition de balles de
tout ce qu'on veut quoi et c'est
forcément on en a un peu moins pour la
chasse on peut encore chasser
rassure-toi mais il y a plus tous les
produits ça c'est sûr
Jean tu chasses un peu toi non parce que
dans ma famille tu chasse pas la
Galinette au sendré non parce que dans
ma famille il y a pas eu de chasseur
j'ai entendu dire mon père un jour que
lui n'avait chassé que à un moment donné
où la la chasse était vraiment ouverte
qu'il était question de vie ou de mort
pour le fait de vivre chez
soi pour le reste il n' ressentait pas
l'utilité mais euh pratiquement dans ma
commune tous les agriculteurs je dis
tous ceux qui restent sont chasseurs
j'ai un fils qui joue au rugby en Top 14
qui a passé son permis de chausser bon
moi je n'en ai pas éprouvé puis
l'utilité puis je laisse m passer
bêtement laisser passer le temps où tu
pouvais aller acheter enfin tu pouvais
avoir ton permis bénévole et j'ai pas eu
le courage de le passer parce que je me
suis dit je l'auraai peut-être pas ma
sœur chasse une sœur qui chasse mon beau
frère aussi il ont d'ailleurs de très
beaux résultats mais je dis heureusement
qu'il y a les chasseurs parce que sinon
tout est labouré il y a plus rien il y a
plus rien pour les animaux et ça
heureusement Willy oui contrôle
d'alcoolémie pour les Ch les chasseurs
oui ou non bah oui j'ai dit que j'étais
pouris pas que tu étais je savais pas
que tu dit que tu étais pour ah si bah
pas sans problème bah je pense que c'est
un peu logique mais mais pour une raison
affreusement pragmatique he même terre à
terre tu crois Sky quand tu es à la
chasse que tu as envie d'avoir un mec à
côté de toi qui a 2 g d'alcool dans sang
et toi tu es là avec ton gamin et et tu
pourrais prendre un coup de fusil la
même chose la même chose pour les
stupéfiants la même chose pour les
stupéfiants quand c'est exagéré bien
évidemment et tu as des gens sous
l'emprise de stupe c'est quand même un
peu dangereux là quand même faut être
clair tu as une arme dans les mains faut
pas faut pas péter un câ alors chasse
pêche on peut comprendre mais alors
corida qu'est-ce que ça vient faire
là-dedans parce que l' l'acte de de
chasse pour manger je veux bien
h par passion aussi oui pour manger si
tu veux pour réguler on peut dire aussi
moi la plus belle la
cor la plus belle des chasses c'est la
chasse récréative c'est celle qui n'est
qu'une transmission et une tradition ça
c'est la vraie chasse on parla des
chasses traditionnelle on ir à la
corrida après les chasses
traditionnelles a une chasse dans la
corrida non d'accord mais je parle d'une
tradition et d'une pratique de des
choses qui sont codifié les mecs des
chasses traditionnell c'est ce que
l'Europe est en train de tuer c'est tout
ce qui nous ramène mè au code et des
héritages qui sont pour certains
millénaires la chasse les chasses dites
traditionnelles c'est quand l'être
humain est pas encore inventé l'arme à
feu c'est ça comment attraper un piaf
avec en faisant un collet tu sais
comment c'est la tendrie des gris trois
crines l' tu sais que c'est la la chasse
à l'pieux bien sûr donc chasse
traditionnelle bah ça fait pas partie
des chasses traditionnelles c'est une
pratique de de de de mise à mort de
l'animal quand il est acculé c'està-dire
c'est comme un grand un couteau posé au
bout d'une d'une lampe ah c'est comme un
jaau quoi voilà c'est ça s'il y a pas
une je te vois bien avec le
javelot dans la jungle c'est pas gentil
ça le coup du javelot dans la jungle non
je suis plutôt chass traditionnel moi
effectivement faire un petit collet pour
attraper une grive avec trois quin de la
un peu braco ouais mais c'est ça on
était quand même moins doué que tous les
animaux qui nous entouraient faut pas
l'oublier heureusement qu'il y a des
gens qui ont convoité le monde animal
pour parce qu'ils avaient faim et qu'ils
voulaient manger c'est sûrement ça qui a
développé la matière grise de tout le
monde et c'est ça qui a fait qu'on est
descendu des armes et qu'on a laissé nos
poils c'est peut-être aussi le fait
qu'on cuisait nos aliments avec le feu
sûrement ça a joué aussi mais pour les
cuirs fallait qu'on les trouve et pour
les trouve fallait qu' on était quand
même physiquement moins bon que tout le
reste et on a survécu et c'est nous qui
sommes qui sommes passés à GIR à la
pyramide de corida je voudrais dire un
mot sur la corida parce qu' hierier soir
nous étions à Bayon euh que que tu
connais euh on peut pas dire que ce soit
quand même une ville qui se distingue il
peent faire faire des passes de rugby
lumineuses la PE Bayona maintenant a
fait le tour du monde depuis le Mondial
c'est quand même une ville
extraordinaire et bien
euh il a fallu aborder sur question le
problème de la corrida parce que à
Bayonne il y a une dizaine de corrida
pendant la feria et commencecent très
tôt et il finissent les plus tard comme
à Dax d'ailleurs les plus grands matador
euh c'est comm ça d'ailleurs que j'avais
connu al Cordobes et son merveilleux
bouquin qui est pas de lui mais de
Dominique Lapierre et de Willy whiteght
où tu porteras mon deuil euh et bien à
Bayonne si nous n'avions pas parlé de
corida et bien ça aurait été mais alors
euh vraiment un drame donc il faut pas
non plus voir tout euh par le prisme euh
de de d'un certain nombre de de d'une
nouvelle intelligigencia qui veut guider
qui veut qui veut imposer com on le
disait très bien Wily sa vision au reste
du monde je peux t'assurer que le débat
sur la corridaa à bon a duré demi-heure
hier soir et il y avait pas que des fou
furieux qui en parla AVC des monsieurs
très bien et qui ne veulent pour rien au
monde renoncer à leur Coray Wily la
corria c'est il est où l'acte de chasse
dans la cor mais il y a pas d'acte de
chasse il y a un un acte il y a un acte
de tradition de transmission et il y a
des code extraordinaire mais comme la
chasse c'est le même princip avant on se
on chassait avec une une peau de bête
qui sentait le renfermer on se mettait
des fausses CNES sur la tête et on
dansait autour du feu en faisant
you et puis on fait bien tu t'en
rappelles ou ouis avec ton maillot de B
pot de bête exactement et puis on a
abandonné oui mais on a quand même gardé
des choses effectivement en nous moi je
peux pas comprend toi c'est tu as gardé
des choses en toi c'estd que tu
tu à la lune c'est ça nonand même pasag
pas je prends effectivement beaucoup de
plaisir à pratiquer la chasse et je me
tu quel est le plaisir que tu prends
parce que tu sais quand tu vois ton truc
s'envoler ou ton tu vois ton TR courir
tu vois tu vois quoi est-ce que tu vois
ton petit réduction de carotte pour le
préparer le soir ben ça en fait partie
d'accord c'est c'est c'est un c'est un
cheminement de tout ça c'estàd c'est une
quête c'est la convoitise du monde
animal évidment c'est la quête c'est un
partenariat avec un animal qui s'appelle
un chien voilà c'est cette recherche
c'est ensuite effectivement avec ton
chien ça c'est ce que tu racontes au
touriste bah c'est comme ça que je le
vis donc tu payes un truc qui coûte hors
de prix pour être dans une chasse tu es
obligé de t'acheter un pétard chasse
dans mon village
donc t'achetter un pétard qui coûte une
blinde je suis pas trop collectionneur
d'armes donc j'ai deux fusils en tout et
pour tout et pourant je le pris en
National donc tu tombes mal je suis pas
un matérialiste donc ça tombe non c'est
pas bon c'est pas mon truc ça mais moi
je trouve que l'acte de
chassou bien sûr que tu te fais l'avocat
du diable je bien et c'est normal Sky
mais c'est pas comme ça que je ressens
les choses je je ressens ou plus poil à
la base beaucoup plus plume et et tu
cuisines quoi alors t tous les giiers
euh tu peux manger je pas un couple de
John perdrero c'est quand même un moment
mais extraordinaire perd naturel tu fais
ça à la cocotte à étouffé mais par
exemple le grand gibier j'aime beaucoup
aussi quand je ramène un sanglier à la
maison par exemple ou un morceau de
sanglier on dire un sanglier euh
systématiquement j'en fais un un Hachi
extraordinaire d'un bout à l'autre et
puis après on mange ça beaucoup
lasagne
hamburger steak mergais saucisse
chipolatas on fait des tas de choses
avec cette viande et d'accord le taureau
dans une Florida il est imbouffable
derrière mais tu rigoles il est mangé il
est mangé rig les gens ils font la queue
religieusement pour acheter un morceau
c'est les fans mais c'est pété d'acide
lactique pourquoi tu dis ça il a été un
petit peu mal mal mené avant oui alors
ça Fran l'histoire de l'acide lastique
mais le stress de l'animal effectivement
donne un goût particulier peut-être au
taureau et encore je pas M lancé
mais tu me l'as redit s'il te plaît le
goût particulier de la viande
stressée tu sais pourquoi on le gibier
on le fait mariner avec des clous de
girof dans du pinard pendant une semaine
ouais parce qu'on aime bien le pinard
oui non mais tu sais pouroi non mais
d'accord tu sais pourquoi oui pourquoi
bah effectivement pour enlever
effectivement cette force un peu spécial
qu' peut y avoir dans la viande parce
que parce que ça a cavalé pendant 27
plombes parce que c'est c'est tout dur
et parce que c'est tout pas bon que es
fort ce côté dur voilà ça attendrait un
petit peu mais c'est pas tout à fait
vrai quand même et la viande chassée à
l'arc elle est meilleure ou elle est pas
meilleure j'ai jamais rien mangé j'ai
pas d'arc donc j'en sais rien du tout je
ne sais pas moi j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il y a un stress particulier que la
viande j'ai déjà mangé la corida c'est
pas un petit peu archaïque écoute pour
un mec qui n'y connaît rien tu arrives
tu as l'impression mais comme à la
chasse tu vois un mec qui fl g oiseau et
là tuas un me un mec qui effectivement
va exécuter un taureau et puis si tu t'y
intéresses si tu essayes de comprendre
ce que ces gens sont en train de décrire
devant toi oui on va dire une espèce de
danse macabre avec un animal mais s'il y
avait pas la corria il serait pas là non
plus parce que l'espèce aurait déjà
disparu et pu personne s'embêterait
effectivement à élever ses animaux
depuis des siècles et quand tu essaes
juste de t'intéressé et tu regardes pas
ça comme un gros con l'extérieur en
disant de toute façon c'est dégueulasse
j'aime pas la corrida tu as qu'à pas y
aller
et ben tu te rends compes qu'il se passe
quelque chose de codifié de très
particulier un espèce d'héritage alors
ça fera bon dire tous les gens qui
aiment pas et ben moi je despends et
puis il y a un moment je vais te dire
j'arrête de vouloir juger tout le monde
et si quelqu'un prend son pied aller
voir ça comme je le fais et ben qu'il y
aille et s'il est heureux comme ça et
celui qu'il aime pas et ben il y a qu'à
pas y aller on gagne beaucoup de temps
moi je vais à la chass ne demande pas à
ce que tous les gens viennent à la
chasse non mais par exemple au nom de
quoi on le ferait pas l'avocat du diable
oui mais je
question le cheval qui veut arrêter
l'quitation parce qu'il aime pas la
corrida il est quand même un peu obligé
de le faire le taureau qui se retrouve
au milieu il est quand même un peu
obligé il a peut-êtreord mais dans ce
cas-là tu veux dire mais dans ce cas-là
on fait quoi c'est tout le monde animal
tout tout ce qui nous tuux pas déguiser
en Taureau non non non non non non j'ai
pas envie de me déguiser en Taureau mais
dans ce cas-là ce que tu remets en cause
Kaa c'est toutes les relation entre le
les hommes et le monde animal non pas du
tout ah ben si leond si le taureau il
veut pas être que le poulet qui vit dans
1 m² avec 12 Cain tu que tu tu un taau
c'est pas un problème si tu le manges
derrière bah bien sûr que mais mais lui
mettre les tortillas comment ça les
picadiiros là comment ça s'appelle le
truc pour bien l'énerver un peu le
chauffer ensuite il va se chauffer
contre le cheval qui est un peu arnaché
pour éviter de se prendre des coups de
déjà il a un mec qui est allé hein pour
raconter ça comme ça TOI tu allé mais
toi tu as jamais eu un beau père
portugais mais parce que quand tu ne
veux pas manger il faut dire pourquoi
que tu veux pas manger mais de quoi la
corida portugaise ou il tue pas le taau
mais ça a été quand même un
scandale tu montes à cheval non tuas tu
as jamais une relation fusionnelle avec
un animal autre que ton cléb non
d'accord quand tu vois l'œil d'un taau
et que tu montes à cheval ça te fait
quand même autre chose
Heou bon on va changer de sujet sinon on
va se fâcher estce que c'est pire est-ce
que c'est pire que de voir un
homme d'avoir un fusil et de te dire
dans 10 secondes je le flingue qui moi
toi hein tu on a parlé longuement de la
guerre B ça dépend à bout porton ou pas
bout porton mais comme tu peux parce
qu'à un moment donné il y va de ta
survie et maintenant on a un peu triché
sur un domaine je connais couperé gens
tu parles de survie pourquoi Emmanuel
Macron a si peur que Vladimir Poutine ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières de l'Ukraine
mais il fait semble en avoir peur il a
peut-être raison non mais non pas du
tout il veut laisser passer les
européennes comme il a laissé passer les
présidentiells il sait très bien que
Poutine ne va pas s ça va le durer
là-dedans il le sait très bien mais je
voudrais revenir
le la corida a tué beaucoup plus de
matador encore que la Formule 1 NAA tué
de pilote sauf qu'on a trouvé le Carbon
la Formule 1 la Formule 1 a tué combien
de de taureau oui mais en comparant ce
qui est comparable comparant ce qui est
comparable il y a il y a une chose on a
trouvé la fibre de carbone pour à la
bagnole qui se désintègre et
malheureusement on a pe Sillé euh la
partie la plus vive du du taureau mais
tous les gramatador sont morts en corida
donc c'est aujourd'hui c'est c'est un
des des des j'avais vu ça au au centre
comment on appelle ça scientifique à
Paris il y a il y a un truc il y a trois
sports qui entraînent les variations
cardiaques les plus violentes l'URE
c'est la course automobile parce que des
frein et cetera l'autre c'est la Corda
parce que quand as effectivement en face
il y a Quême des moments où tu es face à
face et puis l'autre je l'aurais jamais
cru c'est l'alpinisme j'aurais pas cru
que l'alpinisme entraîné de telle
variation cardiaque donc pour revenir
maintenant à l'homme moi je veux te dire
que tu pensis pas tu es un homme et
pourtant l'homme me semble-t-il est
aussi respectable que qu'un taureau euh
lui au moin tu vas pas le bouffer sauf
si tu es vraiment contraint et pourtant
tu vas le tuer si c'est nécessaire mon
Dieu ouis mais tu joues pas un peu avant
avec c'est que j'engueulais un militaire
ukrainien pas très longtemps avec les
vidéos de drone où les mecs s'amusent à
faire 25 tours avant de se faire péter
sur le le militaire adverse en face la
même chose pour
laorida tu pour tu t'amuses pas à
enlever les plumes de ton oiseau avant
de le manger non mais ce qui se passe
avant fait parti d'un tout alors ça se
comprend ça se partage ou ça se partage
pas je peux comprendre vas-y g tu peux
all pisser je t'autorise je vais
discuter lu le café il fait s ses effets
c'est de ma faute non non non non ramène
la bouteille deign qui est audessus du
frigo en repartant
de ouais je disais que ça fait partie
d'un tout que les choses soient
codifiées mais en fin de compte la
relation prédateur prédaté qu'on
reproduit de façon de façon très
particulière il y a rien de cette
relation là je veux bien tu arrivrive à
défendre les chasseurs parce que ils
vont ils vont manger ce qu'ils vont ils
vont ripailler autour de de de l'élément
culturel mais bon m à part on mange tu
comprends tu comprends pas le chasse
chasser alors on tire correctement pour
éviter que la bestiole soit saignée
pendant 1
km fa propr qui tien la route ok bon la
pêche le nokil le machin ok la corida
bah écoute moi franchement j'y vais et
et et j'ai beaucoup aimé cette première
rencontre avec la corrida que j'ai eu un
jour j'y suis retourné alors est-ce que
je suis mal formaté est-ce que je suis
comme les millions de Français qui
adorent ça j'en sais rien mais ça m'a
même paru tout à fait naturel en la
regardant il y a même rien qui m'a
choqué alors que je peux avoir une
sensibilité comme n'importe qui sur des
d'autres choses mais cet instant-là ne
m'a pas paru comme quelque chose de mal
ça m'a pas paru comm as mangé du Taureau
oui B tu parles non mais en question bah
oui évidemment tu penses bien que j'ai
j'ai dû goûter le taureau quelle était
la meilleure viande que tu es pu chasser
et comment elle a été chassée la
meilleure viande que j'ai pu chasser je
je c'est les oiseaux quand même et plus
ils sont petit au meilleur ils sont
alors ça fera bond dire tout le monde
mais il y a une chose que je je mangai
jamais de ma vie et que je regretterai
profondément c'est de manger un orolan
c'est interdit aujourd'hui la chasse à
l'ortelent parce qu'il y en a plus mais
si il y en a plus le droit c'est comme
les griffes c'est comme les Ch tradition
la reproduction mais si a la
reproduction mais si il y a des
orortolans mais on nous a raconté plein
de trucs làd attention il y a un fil là
juste là
g la chasse à la glue tout ça et comment
on a pu se privé ça l'observation de la
nature un oiseau qui se colle
effectivement dans la dans cette C de F
le filant les fils il y a un fil un
deuxè on est bon comment on a pu se
priver de C chasse c'est un vrai
scandale tu sais le peu de gens qui la
pratiqu et regarde on est quand même
dans du dogmatisme parce que toutes ces
chasses traditionnelles qui viennent
d'être retirer rayer de la carte sur un
texte européen c'est quand même beaucoup
plus compliqué de se casser la tête
attraper un oiseau avec un collet
fabriqué avecin les crrains de la C à
cheval ou un oiseau qui doit se coller
aussi qu'on doit siffler qui doit venir
se coller sur un petit bâton de de de
résine de pain ou genre de chosees que
tu peux prendre un fusil et en tuer des
millions le même jour si tu veux c'est
là que tu vois que l'Europe elle
manœuvre quoi c'est pas un problème
d'oiseau c'est pas un problème d'espèce
c'est pas un problème de je dirais de de
de bonne d'état de conservation d'une
espèce c'est juste nous retirer une
tradition comment tu perçois la la
conservation des espèces comment tu
perçois le réchauffement climatique
comment tu perçois les mesures
proactives pour handiguer ou freiner bah
la conservation des espèces on a perdu
beaucoup la chasse a jamais fait perdre
a jamais fait disparaître une espèce
faut le savoir d'ailleurs heureusement
qu'on s'occupe beaucoup de la nature mec
sur les territoires parce que je crois
que ce serait bien pire que ça il y a
une question qui se pose est-ce que
l'agriculture a été responsable de tout
une partie à un moment oui est-ce que
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui je suis
beaucoup plus réservé beaucoup plus
réservé les effs qui ont ét tu parles d'
partie quand tu dis qu'on a supprimé les
bocages qu quand on a mis les pesticides
à gogo quand on a mis tout ça ou mais tu
prends aussi des endroits où on n pas
supprimé les bocages on n pas mis de
pesticid et ça va pas mieux alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe bon aujourd'hui
NotreDame des land il y avait quand même
une diversité magnifique quand on a fait
un tour
là-bas du Triton il en avait en avait
beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs des tritons
j'en dans le fossé de mon au bout de mon
jardin pas BES d'aller qu tu lèves ton
Doig tu sens le sens du vent aussi le
sens du vent on a tout ça partout c'est
pas un problème ça j'entends bien VI
jamais eu au MO 25 ans quand je fais le
tunnel du S qui ne pose plus aucun
problème à personne sauf que l'État
malheure
devant un tel tumulte à renoncer à
mettre la la route en conformité comment
on fait pour vous réconcilier avec les
écologistes mais moi j'ai pas envie
d'être réconcilié avec des gens qui n'y
connaissent rien et qui essayent à peu
près tous les jours de nous détruire
tout ce que nous on aime réconcilier de
quoi je suis pas un écologiste politique
je alors si je te dis si je te alors je
je vais me faire l'avquer du diable je
vais je vais dire mais moi les chasseurs
ils balancent combien de tonnes de
plombs chaque année dans la nature tu
aimes les chiffres donne-moi le chiffre
non mais je te pose la question on nous
dit 40000 tonnes en vérité c'est même
pas 100 tonnes la vérité elle est là on
arrive effectivement à mélanger ta
source tonne de mais mais la nôtre le
nombre de cartouches qu'on utilise parce
qu'à un moment je dis mais à un moment
je me pose bêtement cette question mais
on nous vend depuis des années des
milliers de tonnes de plombé et je me
dis mais après tout comment il compte
ces g là je vais quand même vérifier et
je me dis mais attention qu'est-ce qu'on
mélange on mélange les cartouches sur
les stands de tir ou maintenant obligé
de traiter le plomb etce qui se tire
dans la nature tu sais un gars qui
chasse la plume au village tu crois
qu'il tire 3 400 cartouches par an c'est
que c'est combien de cartouches en
moyenne par chasseur 25 20 20 20 c'est
ça la vérité ça fait combien de tonnes
de plombs en réalité on est plutôt
effectivement on va dire dans les 80
tonnes tout compris et je suis sûr qu'on
peut encore améliorer mais je vais pas
rentrer là 0 tonnes de plomb de plomb en
disant ça fait combien de tonnes avec
les ball trapes dedans alors c'est
compliqué de comprendre par qu'on voit
en en en 10ant ça fait combien de tonnes
80 tonnes ça fait 800 tonnes tu sais
c'est quoi le pourcentage de pollution
du plomb à l'échelle de l'Europe à
l'hectare du plan de chasse 01 % tu
crois qu'on peut pas s'occuper d'autrre
chose avant d'Er les mecs avec leur plan
à la chasse et puis au N de la
bienraitance animale tu sais quand on va
tirer un coup de six acier dans le cul
d'un lièvre on n pas de là de l'arrêter
alors on nousous use avec ça qu'il faut
tuer proprement les animaux on nous met
de la grenaille d'acier on nous met du
substitut ou alors on nous fait quoi on
met du Bismut qui est 50 fois plus
polluant que le plomb tu crois pas qu'il
y a un peu de conneries là-dedans quand
même tu fais référence à quoi là pour
que les gens comprennent bah en fin de
compte l'acier on nous dit on peut plus
utiliser de plomb alors faut savoir que
la grenaille de plomb on arrivve à la
produire en France faut savoir que la
grenaille d'acier elle est obligée de
venir de Chine on n pas les systèmes
pour bon donc on rentre ça en fin de
compte le plomb est un métal avec une
forte densité les grains de plomb donc
quand ça pénètre dans un animal ça le
tue rapidement presque de façon
instantané si tu mets un plomb beaucoup
plus léger hein on a quelque chose qui
pénètre beaucoup moins l'animal donc qui
blesse énormément les animaux et là tu
vas avoir des tas d'animaux qui vont
partir blessés qui vont aller qui vont
durer TR ou 4 jours dans des souffrances
pas possible et là j'utilise un peu ce
qu'on peut des fois nous reprocherin
alors qu'on avait quelque chose qui tu
es bien on dit oui mais ça pollue mais à
côté de ça quand on regarde la quantité
de pollution du plomb tu te dis mais on
se fout de la gueule de qui les
Norvégiens on tu le sais peut-être ont
supprimé le plomb en 2005
toute la chasse du jour au lendemain par
un vote du Parlement ils viennent de le
rétablir en 2018 toute la chasse les
mêmes qu' l'avaient enlevé l'ont remis
pour trois raisons d'abord on s'est
rendu compte que dans le fond le plomb
c'est ce qui polluait le moins et qu'il
vaait mieux utiliser ça que tout le
reste réunit quand même le comble
deuxièmement pour un problème de
sécurité quand tu as des aciers dures
qui vont être mis dans des cartouches
fair commen ça ricoche partout et tu
commences à arroser tout le quartier on
va savoir aussi ce que c'est et la
raison principale et ben la bitraitance
animale parce que que si on veut tuer un
animal proprement bah faut le tuer avec
une cartouche de plomb alors on nous dit
saturnisme on nous dit pollution je
connais pas un mec dans les campagnes
qui est mort un jour de saturnisme on a
tous des parents des grands-parents qui
ont mangé à longueur d'année qui était
quasiment la seule viande qu'ils avaient
sur la table elle était vivère cette
chasse il donc ils ont mangé de la ils
ont mangé il ont avec des plombs je suis
d'accord mais ils en ont forcément mangé
et probablement presque tous les jours
de leur vie et pour pour autant personne
n'en est mort donc là aussi il y a quand
même un petit côté délirant là-dedans
est-ce que tu crois pas qu'il y a
d'autre chose à s'occuper que de venir
nous imposer effectivement d'utiliser de
la grenaille d'acier avec tous les
risques que ça va comporter pour les
êtres humains pour les animaux qui va
devoir devenir du bout du monde avec une
empreinte carbone à la con on pas
déconner quand même est-ce qu'il y a un
sujet que vous souhaiteriez aborder avec
nous moi je voudrais insister un petit
peu plus sur le caractère beaucoup plus
large de notre liste l'alliance rurale
là on a beaucoup
parlé ent de la chasse et des traditions
mais les traditions c'est aussi euh nos
langues et hier soir encore une fois
j'étais à Bayon où on parle euh le
Vernais le Landais gascon on parle
l'espagnol on parle le français et cette
basque don cette langue basque don on ne
sait même pas d'où elle vient ni
l'évasion non plus d'ailleurs et ça
c'est totalement oublié euh dans notre
pays moi j'ai envie de parler de de
désespoir funeste qui dépasse à
l'intensité tout ce que nous avons pu
aborder jusqu'à maintenant c'est-à-dire
et Wily l'a dit tout à l'heure cette
souffrance terrible d'un homme qui a 50
ans et ça va aller à empirant jusqu'à ce
qu'il parte définitivement n'a pas pu
transmettre son exploitation ou alors
son atelier monieur surtout son
exploitation parce qu'il y a une un
caractère de patrimoine dans
l'exploitation toujours on a réussi à la
transmettre après 1418 c'était atroce il
y avait deux frères qui étaient restés
au front il y avait toujours un cousin
il y avait un neveu qui venait reprendre
et maintenant en pleine époque de paix
et auù tout ce de paix je veux dire de
paix relative par rapport quand même au
tranché de de de de de la guerre euh bon
pas encore la guerre sur notre
territoire on se tire par dessus encore
voilà moi je pense que ça c'est un
l'élément qui fait le plus souffrir
parce que ça rappelle la nuit des temps
depuis l'Antiquité l'homme a commencé à
exercer ce métier agrire comme il a
commencé à pêcher et le fait de savoir
que ça euh il ne pourra plus le faire et
qu'il risque lui-même euh de manger de
manquer de quoi manger parce que on en
est là ça le rend vraiment malade et
quand il voit son F parce qu'il y en a
qui n'ont pas envie de reprendre mais il
y en a qui ont envie de reprendre j'ai
la Manias la fille de mon frère qui a
essayé 6 ans de bâtir en vain une
petite une petite ver Jie enfin pour 200
bis ce qui était pas énorme elle a dû y
renoncer elle est repartie reprendre ses
études à l'université de peau et mon
frère reprend l'explloitation comme si
de rien
n'était et il a 5 ans de moins que moi
mais tu ne peux pas savoir ce qu' soir
de la vie ça représente il y a un
sentiment de déclassements pour ces
hommes-là qui disent jusqu'à maintenant
on avait toujours réussi moi je suis un
raté je n'ai pas pu transmettre ça à mon
fils il n pas pu le transmettre parce
que c'est absolument impossible avec le
coûte euh de de la
euh de de de de l'exploitation il faut
discuter avec maintenant le frère la
belle sœur et cetera les charges comme
si ceux qui avaient détenu la propriété
n'avaient pas payé des charges toute
leur vie et puis le fait que
malheureusement il n'y a aucune
formation moi je suis pour qu'on
relanceche l'activité des lycées
agricoles ça fait beaucoup de bien dans
notre pays on n'est pas obligé de passer
autant de temps à
euh mixer l'azote il faut euh beaucoup
plus s'inscrire dans cette optique de
facilitation pour que ce soit toute une
communauté qui facilite c'est une
question de vie ou de mort quelquess ont
dit des voisins et moins d'hectar et et
et et et ça je je trouve ça m'interpelle
au plus haut bois et c'est vrai pour les
artisans quand je vois ces gamins à 14
ans moi qui est connu l'époque où à 14
ans tu étais dans un centre
d'apprentissage et tu avais moitié de
ton temps en théorie moitié de ton temps
en pratique et des fois tu
trouvais celui qui prenait l'apprenti et
l'apprenti des fois reprenait l'affaire
aujourd'hui tout ça c'est fini et tu
traverses des villes de 5 10000
habitants tuas pas un mist TR c'està
dire que cette mort cette mort euh qui
qui qui gagne n compatriotes par toutes
les quelque part qui qui qui est là qui
ne dit pas son nom et qui euh rebondit
très fort avec la perte de l'agriculture
les Français aiment la propriété moyenne
pluriactive il rêve de la retrouver et
ça c'est un chagrin considérable et
c'est un des éléments dont nous avons
fait un des un des point essentiel dans
notre campagne et ça marche très fort
Wily est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaites aborder avec nous un petit mot
comme ça pour terminer euh mais quand
même revenir sur le le fait
qu'aujourd'hui l'Europe est a créé un
truc extraordinaire c'est qu'on est en
train d'enlever la notion de propriété à
tout le monde au nom de la planète
l'Europe a créé un truc formidable qui
c'est que moi je vais appeler le colcose
écologique j'interpelle là-dessus tous
les gens qui m'écoutent ne vous croyez
pas aujourd'hui pas menacer parce que
vous avez qu'un petit appartement ou une
maison avec un petit jardin vous allez
tous y passer vous allez tous y passer
c'est-à-dire que on a créé des systèmes
de lois aujourd'hui et à grand coup de
directive et de réglementation
européenne tu as même plus besoin de
piquer les terres aux gens tu as même
plus besoin de prendre leurs bien il
suffit simplement d'appliquer des lois
de leur mettre des plans de gestion des
contraintes ce genre de choses c'est
quand même un truc de dingue c'est quand
même un truc de dingue hein vous avez vu
quand même ce que c'est aujourd'hui les
herbes protégées qui arrivent vous avez
vu ce que c'est que le le la
restauration de la nature on va mettre
10 % du territoire national français
sous aucune interactivité humaine
qu'elle soit passionnelle traditionnelle
ou économique et il y a encore 20 % qui
vont se rajouter à ça c'est-à-dire le
tiers du territoire français qui va être
soumis à réglementation on est en train
de vous piquer votre droit de propriété
privée de pouvoir faire ce que vous
voulez chez vous un jour on vous mettra
et on en entend parler une taxe au mètre
carré pour votre gazon un jour on vous
interdira de monter sur le dos d'un
cheval un vous vous aurez plus droit de
mettre quelque chose sur votre hameçon
parce que trucider un verre de terre
avec un ason c'est de la psychopathie
c'est de la barbarie on l'entend tous
les jours vous n'aurez plus le droit
d'avoir de chien vous avez vu cette
nouvelle directive bien-être animal qui
arrive qui va être présenté au mois de
septembre détenir un animal de compagnie
ce sera un luxe un luxe que peu de gens
pourront s'offrir parce que quand vous
aurez fait votre ch c'est déjà un luxe
ah mais là là ça va passer à autre chose
là on va passer à à autre chose quand on
voit qu'on va exiger maintenant qu'il
est une lampe la nuit quand on a un
animal de compagnie à côté parce que
s'il se réveille il peut être stressé
quand on voit qu'on demandera aux gens
que les températures soient pas
inférieure à 10°grés ou jamais au dessus
de 25 on n'en fait pas autant pour les
gens on n fait pas autant pour les gens
ça c'est un délire qu'il faut parler la
propriété privée l'espace effectivement
les relations entre les hommes et les
animaux et puis dire à la jeunesse je
t'ouvre je t'ouvre une parenthèse tes
chasseurs tu en connais des des
chasseurs qui laissent dormir leur cléb
dans des dans des conditions il fait
moins moins x degrés dans des espèces de
cheniles où tu en connais des gens qui
s'occupent pas bien ou pas bien de leurs
chiens ah je connais aussi qu'il
s'occupent pas bien de leurs enfants les
emmerd de
moins argument d'autorité c'est vrai
commençons déjà par s'occuper des êtres
humains et s'il y a vraiment des choses
dramatiques qui sont faites on les règle
je veux bien mais faire des directives
pour ça on est en train de casser le
lien qu'on a avec le monde animal comme
le dit com on mesure le degré
d'évolution du une société non oui oui
oui moi je le sais oui oui oui à comment
on traite les hommes et pas comment on
traite les animaux parce que cette phase
toute faite à deux balles je peux te la
dire tous les jours si on veut tu sais
que cette phrase elle est en haut du
grand manège de l'école de guerre je
sais où elle est et je sais qu'il l'a
dit ben moi je peux te dire qu'on
regarde je crois que c'est Gandi
d'ailleurs je je je peux déjà te dire
que au moi je regarde comment il traite
une société avant savoir comment traître
les êtres humains qui composent cette
société on va peut-être revenir aux
fondamentaux quand je vois ce texte de
bientraitance animale je veux dire à
tout le monde qui nous écoute pouzv
oublier les gamins au milieu du jardin
pendant une nuit il fait - 15 vous
risquez rien vous oubliez le chien vous
ferez 15 jours de tole c'est en train de
se mettre en place comme ça il y a un
moment mais bon dieu il faut réagir et
puis pour tout ce qui se passe
généralement faut réagir pour les gamins
et pour les chiens il faut réagir pour
les gamins mais les gamins on s'en fout
et pour les chiens peut-être mais avec
raison c'est un chien il y a des chiens
qui ont passé il y a des chiens qui ont
passé leur vie dans un chenil tu crois
qu'à la ferme on peut mettre tous les
chiens et tous les chats dans la maison
c'est pas possible ils ont une niche ils
dent pas non plus n'importe où et la
pluie c'est pas vrai c'est un chien quoi
je suis d'accord moi j'ai deux chiens
mais c'est deux privilégiers il dent
dans le canapé on le sait tous bon c'est
comme ça voilà mais il y a aussi
d'autres endroits où c'est pas possible
est-ce que pour autant les gens c'est
des salots est-ce qu'il faut leur mettre
un PV est-ce qu'il faut les amener au
tribunal pour ça il y a un moment il
faut qu'on rienne à la mais et les
convois de bestiaux par 40 degr sur
l'autoroute c'est fini pas plus de 2 he
tu as vu parce que 2h dans le camion si
on laisse passer la cette directive
c'est 2h dans le camion c'est 2h en
dehors des camions ah ça va être beau là
hein dans 2 ans quand la directive elle
sera mise en application quand tu auras
pris un bouchon sur le périf de Paris et
que tu auras pas le temps de livrer les
cochons qu'il faudra déposer ça la
première aire de repos de Fontaine Blau
pendant 2 heures à pêtre au milieu au
milieu des vacanciers ah ça va être
grandiose et puis rattraper les poulets
quand on auras Vié le semi ça va prendre
des jours enfin faut arrêter quoi ok
qu'on qu'on fasse des choses il y a
plein de choses intelligent à faire on
l'a mis d'ailleurs ramener les abattoirs
peut-être où ils étaient avant arrêter
de tout vouloir concentrer on est sur
une économie d'échelle d'ailleurs on
fait ça avec les animaux on fait ça avec
les êtres humains aujourd'hui on est en
train de faire faire quoi on essaie de
VO de rassembler tout le monde sur les
métropoles la le monde de demain c'est
un monde urbain et puis la campagne
c'est quoi c'est on ira se promener et
puis on dira ben tu sais il y a un mec
s'appcheral il y a trois sièci était
chasseur voil ce qu'il faisait voil ce
qu'il bouffait voil comment il vivait
VOC quoi il s'habillait dans quoi il
roulait on va finir comme un musée les
gars de la campagne non mais c'est un
truc de on est en plein délire un C15
alors j'ai pas de C15 j'en utilise en ce
moment on s'est marré un peu avec ça
mais c'était un beau pied de nez ce C15
voilà quand tu vois ces gamins à la
campagne qui ont le culte du C 15 ah
évidemment ça fait chier tous les
intellos du coin la seigneurerie la
seigneuie de la sautiserie mais c'est
génial on a joué le perbichet la Cindy à
Kevin aussi on s'est marré avec ça mais
c'était un beau pied de nez je trouvais
que c'était un beau pied de nez parce
que ils ont des valeur ces gamins là ils
ont pas envie d'un monde qu'on veut leur
asceptiser 100 % progressiste et moderne
et qu'on veut leur imposer ils veulent
juste qu'on arrête de les emmerder comme
la plupart des gens d'ailleurs voilà
tout est déjà compliqué mais au moins
laissez-nous ça laissez-nous ce petit
morceau de liberté ben c'est encore trop
pour l'Europe d'aujourd'hui donc il va
falloir changer et puis je comprends pas
que les gamins se révoltent pas je
comprends pas qu'ils aient pas envie de
choisir on n quand même pas déb pas
d'appel à la révolte ouielle pas à la
révolte mais regarde regarde ce qu'ils
ont voté il y a 3 semaines il y a 3
semaines c'était une grande semaine il y
a une journée ils ont discuté à partir
d'une question d'une députée allemande
comment on peut encore dans l'Europe
d'aujourd'hui manger un animal vivant tu
l'as peut-être pas vu mais je te le dis
tu c'était quoi l'animal vivant en cause
l'huîre les mecs ont débattu pendant des
heures pour savoir où elle était la tête
et comment on pouvait etutonasier
l'huîre avant de la mettre dans sa
bouche moi je veux bien qu'on paye des
mecs à réfléchir sur ces questions
fondamentales pour l'existence hein on
est tout à fait d'accord mais il y a eu
autre chose ils ont ils ont interdit et
ça tu as dû le voir la Boîte à Pizza et
le corné de frites il y a 15 15 20 jours
j'apprends devant la télé l'Europe a
fait un truc formidable pour l'écologie
pour la santé on a interdit le cornet de
frites et la boîte à pizza [__] les
mecs c'est du lourd tu as pas vu le
cordon de téléphone pour quelle raison
si mais j'ai vu mais je peux pas tout
prendre les exemples pour en écrire un
bouquin laissem terminé pour le cornet
de frit parce que un mec du pas de calis
à qui on Inter le cornet de frit on est
quand même à deux doigts he de la guerre
civile dans le secteur donc parce qu'il
y a un mec qui a dit un jour qui avait
une interaction qu'ils ont vu il y avait
une possible interaction avec des
microparticules cancéreuses qui
pourraitent nître entre la chaleur de la
paraphine et alors et alors c'est quoi
cette vie asceptisée et moi si j'ai
envie de manger un peu plus que la
normal j'ai envie de fumer si j'ai envie
de coller un coup on commence par les
cornets de frites et les boîtes à pizza
on met où le curseur après dès qu'il y a
un truc qui peut provoquer le moindre
petit problème on le fait plus on n pas
fini de s'emmerder dans nos villes les
enfants ah ça va être ça va être long
les weekends vivement le boulot lundi
matin tu sais qu'on faisait des des
suppositoires au radium avant
oui tu prends tout de suite un cas
extrême tuas quand même pas me dire et
encore si on nous le dit bon allez
allons tirons le fil jusqu'au bout et si
on nous le dit et si j'ai envie de faire
10 ans de moins parce que je me mets un
suppositoire au radium et que je mange
un un paquet de frites dans un cornet de
frites c'est ma vie c'est moi qui décide
si tu si tu me coûtes vachement cher en
soin palliatif av ma vie et bah je je
coûterai un peu un peu cher en soin
palliatif j'essaierai que ce soit un peu
plus court que la moyenne voilà mais
après tout c'est mon choix moi ce que je
veux c'est choisir je
voudrais pu choisir com qu'est- que tu
penses des soins palliatifs et de
l'ethanasie l'aide à mourir je suis
totalement pour
l'euthanasie
voilà je je pense que le lorsque le
corps n' peut plus B oui lorsqu'il a
exprimé l'homme a exprimé à plusieurs
reprises ça pourrait plus durer c'est
pas la peine c'est pas la peine de
parler de souffrance animale ou de
souffrance humaine si c'est pour imposer
au soir de sa vie quand tu ne peux plus
te défendre quand tu veux plus rien
William Willy pardon je voudrais trois
livres à conseiller pour ma communauté
et Paris gens
je dirais le alors il y en a un mais bon
c'est fétiche faut que je lise une fois
par an c'est Siran Bergerac parce que
comme dans le texte que je connais par
cœur je me reconnais dans cette
ririus mais et puis voilà c'est encore
plus beau quand c'est inutile et les
valeurs du panage c'est quelque chose
qui sont fort fort pour moi je trouve
que c'est un merveilleux texte Le
Seigneur des Anneaux parce que c'est un
j'ai queais me dire les mass d'armes du
13e siècle non le Seigneur des Anneaux
parce que c'est un bouquin qui m'a
vraiment fait rêver et je trouve que le
mec qui a écrit ça Tolkien est un type
qui aut faut vraiment avoir un cerveau
en en ébullition et puis sûrement un des
premiers bouquins qui m'a beaucoup
ému allez dans ma toute prime jeunesse
et qui m'a touché c'est Madame Bovary
voilà parce que c'est un des premiers
bouquins que j'ai lu dans ce style de
bouquin qui parlait de sentiments et
d'amour et qui m'a marqué allez j'ai
vraiment essayé d'être un peu le plus
large possible mais ouais c'est trois
livres que je placerai sur quelque chose
qui sont importants pour moi oui Jean
moi je voudrais encourager vivement à
lire la Parole donnée de Jean lassa
cherch
midi très beau livre je voudrais les
encourager à lire au chercheemi toujours
hor ou crépuscule c'est le bin qui m'a
coûté le plus l'énergie j'ai essayé de
remonter jusqu'à la découverte des des
AES des Amériques et du grand plus grand
génocide humain jamais perpétré et
jamais d'ailleurs jugé nulle part et qui
a marqué la fin de monde pour entrer
dans notutre et je voudrais prescrire au
éditions glyph
euh la France authentique de Jean Lassal
c'est Jean Lassal Jean Lassal est-ce que
tu as un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la
mer moi je leur conseille il m'invite
beaucoup dans les Fes
ou dans les grandes universités dans les
écoles d'ingénieurs il m'invite aussi
pour ceux qui ont l'intelligence de la
mer qui poursuit celle du cœur pour
façonner la matière pour ils ont fait
les villes des villes magnifiques en
France demain ils feront les B lieux
j'en suis persuadé elles seront très
réussi moi je je leur conseille de
croire en eux
d'étudier l'instruction est un élément
très essentiel et euh j'espère qu'on
aura la sagesse d'introduire dans
l'instruction publique l'utilisation
d'Internet qu'il subissent beaucoup plus
qu'il ne donne euh qu'il ne qu'il ne
l'utilise et ça c'est vraiment un très
très grand péril pour un très grand
danger mais qu'ils s'accrochent à
quelques idées et qu'ils s'y tiennent
ils ont raison ils sont beaucoup plus
courageux que que nous aujourd'hui ils
osent parler de France ils adorent
chanter la marseillaise ils se sentent
une communauté de destin ce que nous
n'étions pas sûr de faire il y a 25 ans
oui on appelle le 12 on décroche le 17
ou on décroche le 17
on appelle le 12 pour pour les services
de sécurité ouais mais pourquoi tu me
dis ça c'est la question on décroche le
12 ou on appelle le 1elle le
17 pour la même question de genre pour
les jeunes je me permets mais euh je
voudrais qu'ils arrêtent d'avaler tout
ce qu'on leur sert comme soupe et qu'ils
vérifient un peu plus par eux-mêmes pour
ça j'admire beaucoup ce que tu fais
quand tu parles de de de de filet de de
d'imposer aux gens à lire un peu mais
mais mais arrête arrêtez de prendre les
choses comme des acquis vérifiez par
vous-même et faites-vous faites-vous une
idée précise et si on devait recevir un
vieux servir un vieux slogan euh que
j'étais j'ai pas compris à l'époque
j'étais pas né mais que je trouve
vraiment d'actualité si j'étais jeune
aujourd'hui je remettrai un panneau sur
ma bagnole et je marquerai il est
interdit d'interdire et ça c'est pour
l'Europe il est interdit d'interdire il
faut absolument arrêter d'interdire les
choses messieurs merci merci Sky merci
Sky vraiment un moment où on a Pasu
passé le temps magque c'est super merci
beaucoup bravo
[Musique]